Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim und das hier ist Ausgabe achtundsiebzig von UKW,
und heute ist zwar nicht äh Freitag, ist ausnahmsweise fällt diese Sendung auf den Donnerstag und das bedeutet dann aber trotzdem, dass es sich OLO, KW, Corona Weekly handelt mit mir und mit Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Genau, wir haben heute aus Gründen mal den Donnerstag gewählt, wir rollen jetzt so langsam hier auf die Urlaubssaison zu
und da wird's dann zunehmendem Maße schwierig mit der äh Wochenendnutzung. Genau und ähm kann auch gut sein, dass das jetzt erstmal.
Ähm die letzte Sendung wird für die nächsten Wochen, weil's einfach so ein bisschen äh urlaubs äh Phasen angesagt sind. Je nachdem, wie es so läuft und was so passiert und wie wir gegebenenfalls zwischendurch Zeit finden.
Schmeißen wir vielleicht nochmal in die Sendung rein, aber stellt euch jetzt erstmal darauf ein, dass äh wir uns dann bestenfalls äh über Twitter zu Wort melden oder sowas ähnliches.
Mehr und Corona macht ja jetzt hoffentlich auch endlich mal die versprochene Sommerpause, so wie mein wann soll Corona Pause machen, wenn ich im Sommer.
Ja richtig.
Letzten Sommer hat das ja auch funktioniert, ähm wie gut wir uns in diesem Jahr schlagen, das werden wir jetzt gleich alles äh besprechen.
Ja, trotzdem war das äh ganz guter Ritt. Das wird jetzt hier die zweiundfünfzigste Ausgabe sein. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt wirklich äh so Weekly gewesen wären, wie es irgendwie ginge, würden wir jetzt schon seit einem Jahr senden.
Tatsächlich ist es ja schon ein bisschen mehr, aber das heißt, wir haben so.
Zweiundfünfzig Proben genommen von dieser Pandemie und mal so geschaut, was so geht und.
Ich denk wir haben so einiges gelernt und so einiges verstanden und das wollen wir dann glaub ich auch am Ende der Sendung mal zusammenrollen.
Würde ich vorschlagen, schauen wir erstmal auf die Ist-Situation ähm und fangen wie immer mit den Inziden und den Rs und den sonstigen Zahlen aus deinen Aufschlagpavel.
Also die deutschlandweite Inzidenz nach Publikationsdatum äh liegt jetzt bei elf Komma acht pro.
Hunderttausend äh in den letzten sieben Tagen. Also wir nähern uns so langsam den.
Einstelligen Bereich und ja der dazu passende R-Wert,
schwankt so um mich sagen
null Komma sieben fünf herum jetzt seit einiger Zeit. Der springt halt immer ein bisschen rauf und runter. Und wir nähern uns
aber langsam eben auch Inzidenzen, wo der R-Wert eben sehr instabil wird und eigentlich als,
ja Kriterium eben immer
unzuverlässiger wird vor allem je weiter man dann reinguckt wenn man dann in Länder oder gar Kreisebene rein äh schaut dann äh ist der R-Wert eigentlich ja
fast nur noch Makulatur, zum Glück,
Ja, bei der Zahl der Toten, die ist jetzt langsam inzwischen auch gesunken, aber wir sind immer noch äh bei fünfhundertvierundneunzig Fällen.
Das ist so.
Unter hundert am Tag, aber ich finde das immer noch ein ganz schöner Hammer so, also finde, wir sind da noch nicht so wirklich richtig.
Durch an der Stelle aber was man eben von den Intensivstationen äh vielerorts äh hört, dass die seit äh teilweise seit einem,
ja oder seit Beginn der Pandemie äh zum ersten Mal keine Coronapatienten mehr äh auf der,
Station haben bei kleineren Stationen kommt das jetzt.
So vor. Und äh ja, das ist also alles ganz erfreulich äh würde ich sagen und.
Wenn man sich das jetzt nach Altersgruppen anschaut, dann geht das jetzt auch nicht so richtig weit auseinander.
Ähm so bei den bei den Inzidenzen ähm.
Liegen wir in der Altersgruppe achtzig plus, äh also bei den Älteren inzwischen irgendwie deutlich.
Unter einstellig und
bei den höchsten Altersgruppen, also fünf bis vierzehn sind wir noch so in den in im zwanziger Bereich
gerade drin und der Rest bewegt sich so dazwischen, aber gerade natürlich die Altersgruppe eben äh über
sechzig und vor allem über achtzig, dass dort die Inzidenzen jetzt so niedrig sind, das spricht jetzt auch
dafür, dass in den Altersgruppen jetzt die Impfungen äh tatsächlich äh ganz gut durchschlagen einfach, dass.
Sind jetzt sind jetzt die Impfungen in Verbindung natürlich grundsätzlich,
das sind dann auch so selbstverstärkende Effekte, weil je weniger Virus dann da ist, in manchen äh Gegenden, umso äh ja, äh also wo kein Virus ist, kann man sich auch nicht anstecken. Ja.
Es ist auch nicht so, dass alle achtzig Millionen irgendwie zusammen in einer großen Badewanne sitzen würden oder in irgendwie unter einem Dach.
Sondern äh sobald die Inzidenzen natürlich jetzt runtergehen äh reist es quasi auf, das heißt du hast dann halt einfach eben ganze Gegenden, da ist dann,
möglicherweise gar kein Virus mehr und das muss da halt erst wieder hinreisen, damit sich das da wieder ausbreitet. Das ist natürlich ganz schön.
Ja und hm wenn es von irgendwo.
Wieder ausgehen sollte, so Altersgruppen mäßig, gerade die R-Werte vergleicht.
Marschieren die überall fast im äh Gleichtakt außer äh bei jetzt den, ja, null bis Vierjährigen, also bei den Kita-Kindern interessanterweise.
Ist der R-Wert in der, in den letzten sieben Tagen wieder gestiegen ist, eigentlich immer noch bei null Komma acht, also wir haben's da,
in der Altersgruppe noch mit sinkenden Zahlen zu tun, aber äh das ist sagen die ein einzige Auffälligkeit während bei den anderen Altersgruppen,
Werte mehr oder weniger im Gleichtakt äh marschieren gerade. Ja.
Und äh wie schon gesagt, äh wir sind dieses Jahr ein bisschen spät dran mit der Corona-Sommerpause.
Im letzten Jahr waren wir ja direkt Inzidenzvergleichsmäßig.
Ende April ungefähr da, wo wir jetzt sind, aber da war halt die Dunkelziffer eine andere und,
wenn man da jetzt die Testzahlen mit hinzunimmt,
ist es trotzdem noch so, ja, äh dass wir ungefähr ähm.
Bei der positiven Quote, wo wir, wo wir jetzt liegen, nämlich, was waren das, zwei Komma.
Drei eins Prozent und da lagen wir halt zuletzt.
Irgendwo inzwischen der KW ja neunzehn rum. Jetzt ist äh haben wir die Kalenderwoche dreiundzwanzig. Also ja gute vier Wochen.
Später dran sind wir jetzt also zwischen drei und fünf Wochen ungefähr.
Ähm ja hat uns diese dritte Welle äh jetzt leider vom vom Frühjahr und vom Sommer jetzt schon geklaut quasi.
Hm, die vermeintliche dritte Welle.
Ja, was heißt vermeintlich? Ja gut, meinst du, es ist war noch eigentlich die Zweite.
Naja, ich meine, haben wir ja nun auch schon oft öfter gesprochen, machen wir vielleicht am Schluss auch nochmal. Ich ich halte die für,
Das war das, das war der Teil, den wir wirklich äh hätte vermeiden können.
Ist auch der Teil, den man am einfachsten hätte vermeiden können und der von daher eigentlich der eigentliche Skandal ist.
Gut, egal. Lass uns das mal bei den Zahlen bleiben. Also positiv Quote zwo Komma drei äh Prozent, das ist gut, ja, das heißt, es ist weiter runtergegangen. Es sinkt jetzt nicht mehr ganz so schnell
da lohnt sich ja der Blick auf die Grafik, die wir im Übrigen, die Grafiken, die wir hier besprechen, also diese Zahlenausschnitte, die finden sich ja auch immer im Blog wieder, ne, falls ihr das mal äh auch äh vor dem geistigen, nicht nur vor dem geistigen Auge, sondern auch vor dem
Auge haben wollt, das äh haben wir dort alles immer eingestellt. Ähm.
Ich bin ja ein großer Freund von dieser Positive, weil man der so schön den Verlauf ansehen kann, ne? Das ist so die die gemittelste Linie überhaupt
immer so mit ein bisschen Verzögerung, aber sie sagt einem auch immer ganz klar den Trend. Also wenn die positiv Quote steigt, dann ist schon meistens.
Das ist schon ein bisschen problematisch so. Und vor allem, wenn sie über fünf Prozent steigt, dann dann ist das problematisch.
Aber wir haben den ganzen Sommer über letztes Jahr nochmal eine niedrige gehabt wie jetzt und das ist durchaus auch etwas, was wir äh weiter anstreben sollten. Sieht aber auch danach aus, dass es noch eine Weile
sinkt, bevor man wieder Aussagen über die Zukunft machen kann.
Ja, also auch bei den Uni-Testzahlen, da sind wir jetzt bei achthundertzweiundzwanzigtausend Tests pro Woche.
Die also in der dreiundzwanzigsten Kalenderwoche bis zum dreizehnten sechsten.
Stattgefunden haben und so viel Tests hatten wir ja äh ungefähr in der Kalenderwoche dreiunddreißig letzten Jahres zuletzt bei einer.
Positiven Quote von null Komma neun acht Prozent. Ja, das heißt, wenn man das jetzt vergleicht, gleiche Anzahl von Tests und äh positiven.
Ungefähr, dann äh ja, kann man sagen, wir sind noch nicht. Unten angekommen. Also wir sind noch.
Deutlich Faktor, zwei bis drei.
Über dem wo wir halt vor einem Jahr waren und wo wir eben auch ankommen sollten und wo wir dann auch in zwei, drei Wochen hoffentlich ankommen.
Tja, das wäre auf jeden Fall gut.
Ja. Zwar nehme ich auch bei einer positiven Quote von unter ein Prozent. Das ist dann sagen eher ja.
Noch tolerabel. Ähm und äh dann eben niedrige, einstellige Inzidenzen. Schauen wir mal.
Was ja so ein bisschen der äh Elefant im Raum ist, ist ja hier unsere gute Variante Delta.
Ehemalig indische Variante oder auch B eins äh sechshundertsiebzehn Punkt zwei, die ja immer noch Großbritannien äh unsicher macht.
Und
Hat da auch neue Zahlen veröffentlicht, wie es in Deutschland aussieht, wie äh wie es in in England, also in Großbritannien vor allem aussieht, weiß man auch. Neunzig Prozent aller Infektionen
eben mit dieser Variante statt. Das heißt, sie hat komplett übernommen
und ja, die Inzidenzen steigen noch in Großbritannien und das ist ja das, was äh auch alle hier so ein bisschen nervös macht, ne? Andererseits scheint es auch derzeit so ein Phänomen zu sein, was auf,
Britannien beschränkt ist und sich nicht so ohne Weiteres auf andere Länder übertragen lässt. Nichtsdestotrotz.
Meint das RKI, dass wir derzeit ungefähr einen Anteil von sechs Prozent haben, ne? Wohlgemerkt, diese Zahl bezieht sich auf Neuinfektionen,
die es gibt. Und sechs Prozent davon,
sind halt dieser Variante zuzuordnen. Das sind aber insgesamt absolut gesehen derzeit relativ geringe nämlich zweistellige Zahlen, ne? Davon reden wir derzeit.
Aber eben auch, was hatten wir gesagt? Siebzig, achtzig Fälle ungefähr pro Woche war das nicht. So die Größenordnung oder sogar deutlich mehr. Moment.
Fünfundsiebzig habe ich, glaube ich, jetzt so gerade im Ohr.
Ja.
Ja nur es sagt halt nichts darüber aus. Also so lange es nicht weg ist, ist es halt noch da und solange es noch da ist, kann's halt immer mal wieder so ein super Spreader äh erwischen,
und ja, findet halt einfach statt. Also das ist rein rechnerisch möglich ist, sieht man an Großbritannien,
dass es nicht unbedingt so sein kommen äh so sein,
muss, dass es nicht unbedingt so kommen muss, sieht man vielleicht dann, weiß nicht, an Israel, also es gibt ja auch andere Länder.
Äh vergleichbare Fortschritte haben, wo das jetzt nicht stattfindet und,
gibt natürlich auch noch ein paar andere Erklärungsmuster, unter anderem womit geimpft wurde, ne, also dass vielleicht der hohe Anteil von Asra Senica
ähm in Großbritannien dazu beigetragen hat, dass die Widerstandsfähigkeit gegen Variante nicht so hoch ausgeprägt ist, wie sie man's gerne hätte.
Ja, das wäre interessant zu wissen, ob dem so ist ähm.
Weil äh wenn dem so wäre, wäre natürlich gut beraten, äh jetzt alle, die eine erste Dosis Astra bekommen haben, äh vielleicht dann als zweite Dosis eben ein RNA Impfstoff.
Zu geben.
Weil äh ja sonst, ich weiß gar nicht, wie hoch ist denn bei uns der der Astra-Anteil eigentlich, heißt das so ungefähr im Kopf bei den Gesamt, bei den Erstimpfungen jetzt.
Du meinst jetzt kumulativ, wie viel Prozent aller Impfungen mit Astra durchgeführt worden sind.
Im Kopf habe ich das nicht, aber das könnte ich mal versuchen noch nachzuschlagen.
Ähm der Großteil ist bei uns auf jeden Fall Biotontech und auch moderner ist äh im Prinzip ähnlich stark vertreten wie wie Asra Senica. Ähm.
Ich kann mal äh schauen, ob ich die Zahl generieren kann.
Ja, weil was.
Mich nämlich da so ein bisschen beunruhigt hat, war das ja zumindest äh was Astra Seneka betrifft. Darum die südafrikanische Variante dort ähm.
Ziemlich ja um den Impfstoff sich herum.
Mutieren äh konnte und dem dem ausweichen konnte. Und.
Das hat natürlich so ein bisschen mein mein Grundvertrauen äh dann äh was Varianten betrifft, erschüttert äh und Astrasinika.
Jetzt während.
Ja ist von den MRNA Impfstoffen solche Nachrichten nicht gab, wobei es auch schon äh durchaus äh die eine oder andere Variante dann.
Ja, aber ein bisschen mehr Leute erreichen kann, die bereits geimpft worden sind. Ja.
So, ich habe das mal hier kurz nachgeschlagen. Also, wenn ich das richtig.
Sehr macht äh derzeit ungefähr zweiundzwanzig Komma fünf Prozent der Erstimpfungen aus.
Ist schon ein bisschen mehr, als ich dachte.
Also wir haben knapp neun Millionen Impfungen damit gemacht. Äh also acht Komma neun Millionen moderner, sind so drei Komma drei Millionen und Biotech sind so siebenundzwanzig Komma fünf Millionen rausgegangen.
Mhm. Ja, das klingt doch ganz gut.
Hatten wir, glaube ich, auch schon mal angesprochen. Ich denke halt, es gibt es gibt einfach dieses Problem, dass halt viele Leute Asra Senica,
nicht nehmen wollen, so, weil's irgendwie einen schlechten Ruf äh geraten ist, durch diese Thrombosengeschichte, alles nachvollziehbar. Durch dieses hin und her mit dem Alter und dann irgendwie auch noch diese Lieferprobleme, also es ist relativ wenig passiert,
wo Asrasitika mal geglänzt hätte, ja? Und die einzige positive Nachricht, die man ja eigentlich so machen kann, ist, wirkt geil in Kombination mit Beyonte. Und wenn man diese Kombi-Impfung einfach mal gezielt,
ansetzen würde, sagen würde, ja, okay, hier Astrasiniker zum Ersten, aber dafür gibt's dann auch äh Bier und Tech zum Zweiten und das wirkt noch mal gegen alle Varianten besser,
Das würde eben den Absatz von Asra Sindika äh erhöhen, damit dann äh Bier und Tech freimachen, quasi ähm für nur für Zweitimpfung. Also.
Ich bezweifele zwar das, dass es jetzt eine Strategie ist, auf die man jetzt noch äh wechseln will, aber ich sehe ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig, was dagegen sprechen würde.
Ja, wahrscheinlich reichen die Zahlen dann halt am Ende dann doch wieder für die STIKO nicht
oder so, da gibt's halt, ja, zwar die Studie irgendwie aus Spanien, äh, glaube ich, die
die besten Ergebnisse gezeigt hat, aber ja, nur weil in Spanien irgendwas funktioniert, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass das in Deutschland auch so funktioniert oder wirkt und das sage ich jetzt nur so halb sarkastisch.
Na gut, aber es gibt auch die Studie von der Charité, ne. Die haben wir ja auch schon
die war jetzt zwar nicht ganz so euphorisch, aber die hat ja jetzt zumindest nicht gesagt, dass es schlechter wäre, sondern schon besser, wenn auch nicht so viel besser, wie es die Spanier behauptet haben. Also
Das ist durchaus so ein Punkt, wo man sagen kann, da da gibt's äh sehr wohl Überlegungen. Auf jeden Fall ist es klar, dass es funktioniert, ist auf jeden Fall klar, dass es
nicht schadet. Und wenn es eben in dieser Kombi-Strategie sich dann eben auch besser unters Volk bringen ließe, dann äh wäre das ja schon mal was.
Und wenn man so ganz nebenbei auch noch mehr äh Variantenresistenz dabei erzeugt why not. Na egal, also die Arbeit der kümmert da jetzt nicht abnehmen äh ist halt so, wie es ist.
Muss man sich halt selbst persönlich entscheiden.
Genau, wir werden ja eigentlich jetzt bei der, bei dieser Variante Delta retten jetzt bei Clubhaus am,
ähm ja, gestern am Mittwoch äh auch nochmal äh mit der Runde darüber gesprochen, da äh wurde auch nochmal nachgefragt
warum denn unsere Prognose nicht eingetreten sei, nach der ja alles ganz schlimm wird? Ich so, was Prognose im Moment, da muss ich erstmal drüber nachdenken,
angesprochen wurde, war unsere Reflexion dieses Blogbeitrags von dem Dirk äh.
Sla, der mittlerweile zu diesem Blogbeitrag auch noch ein Update geliefert hat. Ähm da muss man einfach nochmal sagen.
Eine Modellrechnung.
Es ist nicht ein, das wird so kommen, sondern das ist ein, wir haben hier bestimmte Parameter, äh wir müssen immer ein paar Annahmen machen, ich mache jetzt hier mal ein paar Annahmen und wenn die halt eintreffen, dann könnte es sich so entwickeln.
Und ich erinnere mich genau, dass wir da zugesagt haben, äh ja, so sehen die Modellrechnungen im Moment aus, aber.
Es wird nicht so kommen. Wir wissen zwar nicht warum, aber
es wird nicht so kommen so, ja, da haben wir tatsächlich mal ähm sagen, also ich zumindest so vom vom Gefühl her einfach
vielleicht entwickelt man so, wenn man anderthalb Jahre fast täglich auf die Zahlen
guckt, entwickelt man vielleicht auch so im Hinterkopf, sondern äh Prognose, Netzwerk, sondern neuronales, was da so im Hintergrund arbeitet und dann
eben auch irgendwie so intuitiv Vorhersagen macht, ohne dass man jetzt genau begründen kann, äh warum äh so das gucken,
kommt halt nicht dann ins Bewusstsein, aber sagen das Gefühl kommt dann ins Bewusstsein, dass hm, ja, eigentlich müssten die Zahlen jetzt irgendwie.
Hochgehen äh so bei den ganzen Lockerungen, aber es sieht nicht so aus, als würden sie's tun.
Es gibt Fakten und es gibt gefühlte Fakten. Das, was anderes als Alternative Fakten, ja, damit wollen wir nichts zu tun haben, aber für gefühlte Fakten sind wir durchaus zu haben.
Äh
Genau, wir verlinken auf das äh Update. Wir haben da jetzt nicht zu tief reinge äh reingelesen, was das uns noch alles äh sagen kann. Ähm wer Interesse hat, kann das gerne äh gerne machen.
Dann gab's noch eine schöne Aufarbeitung bei der Zeit,
Ähm die haben sich mal diese ganze Auswertung der Zahlen
in Städten angeschaut und nochmal separat ausgewertet. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo sie diese Daten so genau herhaben. Auf jeden Fall ähm
sind da Karten bei rausgekommen für verschiedene Großstädte in Deutschland. Das sind konkret, Berlin, Hamburg, München, Köln, Stuttgart
Düsseldorf, Dortmund, Essen, Dresden und Nürnberg.
Und wenn man da so drauf rumklickt, sieht man halt so die typischen Stadtkarten, aber eben die einzelnen Stadtteile entsprechend getönt mit wie viel äh Fälle dort denn,
aufgetreten sind. Also wie schlimm hat es bestimmte Stadtteile getroffen? Und,
daraus kann man halt einerseits ablesen, dass ja, dass dass jede Stadt hat so ihre Pappenheimer.
Definitiv so, die ähm regionalen Unterschiede sind signifikant. Jetzt weiß ich auch nicht ganz genau,
wie jetzt diese Daten so sind,
Was ich mich auch immer wieder frage bei dieser ganzen Melderei, was ist eigentlich letzten Endes entscheidend, wo man sich irgendwie infiziert hat oder wo man wohnt oder wo man getestet wurde.
Gut, aber ich denke, das gleicht sich so ein bisschen aus und hat dann doch schon ein bisschen mehr mit Wohnort zu tun. Ich kann jetzt bestenfalls für Berlin sagen.
Ne, das da das kenne ich so ein bisschen und Hamburg, also in Berlin ist es halt vor allem Mitte äh aber auch ganz stark eben Neukölln.
Ähm beim Mitte kann ich's mir ehrlich gesagt so recht nicht erklären, außer dass das im Wesentlichen eigentlich ja,
Also mit dem Wedding gehört da noch so ein Stadtteil dazu, der ähnlich wie Neukölln in der in der Bevölkerungsstruktur ist, ne und wo.
Und Tiergarten.
Tiergarten, also wo einfach so ärmere äh Haushalte unterwegs sind, die generell mir einfach stärker betroffen zu sein scheinen. Ähnlich ist es zum Beispiel in Hamburg mit dem Stadtteil Wilhelmsburg
ne und äh bei der anderen Städten kenne ich jetzt so die äh Struktur nicht, deswegen kann ich mich da nicht groß zu äußern. Ja
lernen wir daraus, dass ähm
So Inzidenz ist nicht gleich Inzidenz, ne? Also das ist äh diese allgemeinen Zahlen, insbesondere dieser Gesamtblick auf Deutschland ist schwierig. Man muss schon die Unterscheidung im Feinen machen und äh
Man kann halt in so einer Situation einfach nicht genug Daten haben,
wie glücklich wir mit der Datenlage waren in dieser Pandemie bisher. Das haben wir ja glaube ich schon mehrfach zum Ausdruck gegeben, vielleicht nicht wieder einen weiteren Rand äh hinten anstellen, aber das muss sich auf jeden Fall verbessern.
Ja. Ja.
Wie schön es doch wäre, ich meine es gibt halt die Bevölkerungsdichte, äh gibt's glaube ich so im fünfzig Meter Raster, so fünfzig mal fünfzig Meter, kannst du dann.
Sagen Rasterpunkte, Rasterdaten kriegen, wo dann in jedem Rasterpunkt drinsteht, wie viele Leute da wohnen. Wie geil wäre es jetzt, wenn's jeden,
Monat oder jeden Tag irgendwie äh diese äh Rasterpunkte gebe mit äh wo denn jetzt gerade äh Neuinfektionen stattfinden, ja. Aber,
ja dann würden die Leute ja in Panik verfallen, weil sie sehen irgendwie
Oh mein Gott, in meiner Gegend sind jetzt fünf neue Fälle. Gleich um die Ecke aufgetreten, aber vielleicht ist ja genau das, was man das, das, was man eigentlich wollen würde.
Ja
Mich sehen können, wie sieht es jetzt so in meiner unmittelbaren Umgebung eigentlich aus mit Neuinfektionen so passieren da welche oder nicht?
Sind um mich herum Infizierte gerade oder nicht. So und meiner Meinung nach könnte man das schon.
Machen. Ähm ich sage mal, man müsste das jetzt dann nicht unbedingt jetzt dann auch noch mit mit den Altersdaten oder Geschlecht oder sonst irgendwas verknüpfen.
Aber die Information an sich, dass in irgendeinem, ich sage mal, fünfzig mal fünfzig oder meinetwegen auch äh zweihundert mal zweihundert Meter äh äh
äh Umfeld äh dort Infektionen stattfinden könnte doch sehr positive äh Auswirkungen auf das Verhalten der Leute sein und auf die Schutzmaßnahmen, die sie ergreifen.
Gut, ähm kommen wir mal zu den Impfungen.
Impfkampagne, die äh läuft ja,
relativ äh stabil im Rahmen dessen, was eben durch die Lieferungen der ganzen Impfstoffe möglich ist. Ähm,
ich habe jetzt hier in den letzten Tagen
war das Ganze Zahlenmaterial, vergleichsweise äh unaufregend, also wir befinden uns halt immer noch in dieser vierten Phase, haben derzeit eigentlich so einen Lauf von relativ viel Impfeaktivität von
mehr als achthunderttausend Impfungen pro Tag im
im sieben Tage Wochenschnitt berechne ich das immer, weil da, ne, wissen schon, christliche Logistikfunktion und so weiter. Ähm.
Wir sind jetzt ganz kurz davor und ich denke, zum Zeitpunkt der Veröffentlichung dieser Sendung, kann man wahrscheinlich schon äh feststellen, dass wir so fünfzig Prozent der Leute, also der Bevölkerung sind äh,
einmal geimpft worden und oder mit Johnson und Johnson geimpft worden äh und dreißig Prozent,
werden die Zweitimpfung erhalten haben.
Also tatsächlich sind wir jetzt gerade bei neunundvierzig Komma fünf sieben und achtundzwanzig Komma sieben sechs, aber Ende dieser Woche wird äh das auf jeden Fall erreicht worden sein.
Ja und das ist so ganz äh ja, ganz schöner Meilenstein, das reicht natürlich jetzt äh äh nicht so recht und vor allem sind wir ja jetzt auch gerade in dieser Phase, wo wir vor kurzem noch dachten, jetzt geht's richtig los
äh weil jetzt kommt ja ganz viel Impfstoff, das äh findet nicht statt. Das ähm.
Das werden wir gleich nochmal vorstellen. Basti, hast du Fragen zu den Impfzahlen als Seuchen? Die sind vergleichsweise.
Unspektakulär angestiegen und vor allem schließt sich so ein bisschen grade halt jetzt diese ähm
dieser Abstand von erst zu zweit Impfung. Das war jetzt so eine Auswertung, die ich gestern mal oder heute das erste Mal gemacht habe, dass ich mal das so in Relation gesetzt habe.
Derzeit sind quasi so äh vierzig Prozent der der äh Impfungen, der Erstimpfung stehen sozusagen noch aus.
Das wird jetzt immer ähm immer niedriger. Man will sozusagen, dass diese Zahl äh gegen null geht, ne.
Wenn das Verhältnis bei null Prozent ist, so dann sind halt äh alle auch das zweite Mal geimpft worden,
wie diese ganze Zuteilung ist, wer jetzt was als Zweitimpfung bekommt, das irgendwie immer noch unklar. Also es äh ich habe so den Eindruck, relativ viele Leute mit
Asra als Erstimpfung sind ins Biontech oder moderner Lager gewechselt. Wir hatten äh
eigentlich hätte, hätte sehr viel mehr Zweitimpfungsaktivität da sein müssen und das,
wurde dann von den anderen Impfstoffen irgendwie aufgefangen, gab jetzt letzten ein, zwei Tage das erste Mal überhaupt so ein so ein nennenswertes
ansteigen bei den Zweitimpfungen, aber das ist immer alles noch weit von dem entfernt, ne. Insgesamt sind wir aber jetzt so langsam über den Berg. Das heißt, jetzt in der nächsten Woche werden wir sehen, dass die Erstimpfung wieder ansteigen.
Und weil einfach dieser ganze ja
Restberg von Zweitimpfungen, der jetzt anstand äh einfach jetzt kleiner äh geworden sein wird und,
Dementsprechend wird sich das dann wieder so ein bisschen umdrehen, das Verhältnis. Aber ist noch ein gewisser Weg zu gehen, ist auf jeden Fall jetzt im Juni noch das Thema. Und Ende Juni, Anfang Juli, denke ich mal, werden wir wieder mehr Erstimpfungen sehen als Zweitimpfung.
Ja
gerade, dass das Ganze eigentlich so ein bisschen so ein System wie äh Schwingung in Kommunizierenden Röhren äh ist, ja, bei konstanter oder bei beschränkter Impfstoff äh zufuhr, sagen,
ähm erstmal quasi,
Erstimpfungen aufzubauen, so dann äh gehen die Erstimpfungen zwangsläufig zurück, weil dann irgendwann äh die Zweitimpfungen äh kommen,
so, was dann dazu führt, dass dann wieder mit Verspätung dann irgendwann
weniger Zweitimpfungen durchgeführt werden müssen und dann wieder sagen mehr Erstimpfungen und so pendelt das wahrscheinlich ein bisschen dann hin, hin und her, bis dann irgendwie Impfstoff im im Überfluss enthalten.
Da sein wird, ja.
Also das ist wirklich äh sehr schwer vorherzusagen, zumal das eben auch immer von den jeweiligen Lieferzahlen abhängt. Und mittlerweile hat jeder Impfstoff mal geschwächelt
Also das einzige, was bisher eigentlich immer stabil war, war moderner und da es dann letzte Woche mal eben eine Lieferung von fünfhunderttausend, was so in etwa der Wochenlieferung entspricht, äh einfach ausgefallen.
So, da kam irgendwie dreizehntausend. Impfdosen und das ist natürlich dann auch für so Impfzentren total schwierig, die dann auf moderner
äh spezialisiert sind, ne, die können dann im Prinzip die ganze Zeit überhaupt nichts machen. Die Impfzentren sind auch einfach.
Ganze Zeit unter ausgelastet gewesen. Also ich habe das hier in der Arena in Berlin äh mitbekommen und,
die haben da so viel Kapazität in diesen Impfstraßen, die könnten also locker äh das Dreifache da durchjubeln, ne, wenn sie einfach nur genug Impfstoff hätten, dass sie,
die einzige wirklich begrenzende Ressource.
Ja. Aber die sind schon also äh ja, diese Impfzentren äh ist schon krass, was da so
wie viel Leute da auch äh irgendwie arbeiten und äh wie das so aber auf Durchsatz auch organisiert ist, wie viel Parallelverarbeitung äh sie da äh haben
so das äh finde ich schon sehr beeindruckend in den großen Impfzentren.
Ja, es ist echt gut äh organisiert und man merkt dann auch sofort, warum man so was in so einer Pandemie auch haben will. Also äh das ist einfach das
am Anfang gab's ja so diesen Schrei, ja die Arztpraxen, die Arztpraxen, die werden uns retten, die müssen das jetzt irgendwie machen und das kam dann auch teilweise von so
Vertretern von von dieser gelassenen Ärzten, ne, wo ich halt sage so, ja okay, gut, kann ich verstehen, dass ihr dann äh auch.
Scheibchen vom Kuchen haben wollt, so klar,
Aber auf der anderen Seite ist die Belastung der Arztpraxen natürlich auch enorm hoch, weil das natürlich alles sehr viel Zeit frisst,
und die ähm ja, dann entsprechend extra Tage einlegen müssen oder dass dann eben davon ab
geht äh von ihrem normalen Geschäft und sich um normal die äh Patienten zu kümmern, wo er im Prinzip auch die genug Zeit da ist. Also von daher habe ich diesen Beruf nie so ganz verstanden. Nichtsdestotrotz
Die Praxen machen einfach gut, muss man grad mal schauen, wie wir da jetzt gerade äh stehen.
Ja, die Praxen hm hauen derzeit ungefähr so sechsundfünfzig Prozent der Impfungen weg. Ne,
Aber die Impfzentren könnten mehr machen. Also es ist einfach rein von der Kapazität her, hm also.
Bin mir jetzt nicht sicher, ob das für alle Impfzentren gilt, aber es gilt auf jeden Fall für manche Impfzentren. Da ist äh äh durchaus mehr möglich, das äh skaliert hoch
so ein bisschen schwierig werden in der nächsten Zeit, weil oft für diese Impfzentren ja so Veranstaltungslocations angemietet wurden, die jetzt auch langsam mal wieder Veranstaltungen machen wollen.
Also, das wird sicherlich auch nochmal ein Thema, äh, werden.
Aber ja auch gut, aber es äh summa summarum, es geht voran, es wird so viel geimpft, wie geht, wie die Lieferung ermöglichen und eben mir ist da relativ wenig
negativ aufgefallen, außer dass diese Zahlenlieferungen von dem RKI wirklich strange sind, also zum Beispiel gab's gestern dann wirst das kennen, ähm von einem Tag auf den anderen. Ich schaue halt immer, was so an Nachmeldungen kommt, dass es ohnehin äh immer so ein gewisser Blog
mal sind das so zehn, zwanzig, dreißigtausend, mal sind's aber auch mal hunderttausend, die an einem Tag nachgemeldet werden, also nicht von dem Vortag, sondern von allen Tagen. Da ändern sich dann
ganz viele Zahlen, wenn nicht sogar alle der letzten Monate immer wieder solche Korrekturen, aber gestern waren's dann halt einfach mal hundertvierundzwanzigtausend weniger.
Also hundertvierundzwanzigtausend Erstimpfungen.
Ja genau, die einfach vorher da waren und die dann einfach wieder zurückgingen. So, auf einmal war der Nachmeldungsblock halt negativ.
Heute kamen dann wieder hunderttausend dazu, wo man jetzt auch nicht weiß, okay, war das jetzt ein Fehler und ist der korrigiert worden oder war das, ist das die Korrekt,
summe von allen Fehlern oder ist da irgendwas nicht gemeldet worden und deswegen wirkt sich das so aus, also total unklar.
Also ich hatte nur mitbekommen, die stellen gerade das Erfassungsverfahren um und haben irgendwas gesagt von wegen
ja das verspätete Meldungen nicht mehr angenommen werden irgendwas in der Art was das jetzt genau bedeutet,
und wie sich das dann auf die Zahlen auswirkt und ob sie jetzt doch noch dann angenommen werden, weiß ich nicht, aber ja, das äh hatte ich zumindest.
Verspätete Meldung von Impfung nicht annehmen, also sorry, wirklich. Also da da gehe ich jetzt nicht mit so. Da muss man sich am Ende dann nicht über eine niedrige Impfquote äh wundern, wenn man sie einfach nicht gezählt hat. Das geht doch nicht. Also das das äh das.
Halte ich mir die Ohren zu, das will ich gar nicht hören.
Irgendwie auch falsch kommuniziert worden oder ich hab's falsch verstanden, aber so so,
können wir vielleicht noch das Original, vielleicht finde ich das ja noch, wo ich das, wo ich das gelesen habe. Ich glaube, auf der RKI Seite habe ich das gelesen. Ähm.
Ja anyway ähm.
Ich weiß nicht, äh zu der STIKO äh Impf Empfehlung äh,
da hattest du jetzt nicht allzu viel dazu gesagt,
Ähm wir hatten das zwar in der letzten Clubhaussendung oder in einer Clubhaussendung äh hatte ich schon mal mich dazu geäußert, aber ich glaube nicht, im letzten Podcast, insofern
vielleicht sinnvoll da doch nochmal ein bisschen äh reinzugehen, zumal wir uns ja auch so
zu dem Thema äh Impfung bei äh Kindern auch äh schon mal geäußert äh hatten.
Richtig. Genau, also äh ich glaube, wir hatten in der letzten Sendung äh waren wir kurz davor, dass die STIGO ihre offizielle
ähm ja offizielles Statement zu Kinderimpfungen macht. Das kam dann, dann haben wir aber nicht gesendet
Deswegen lag das jetzt hier noch auf Halde und kommt schon wieder uns so ein bisschen vor wie gestern, weil's ja eigentlich auch News ist
Ja, genau, also hat sich jetzt sozusagen dazu geäußert, wie sind das jetzt mit äh zwölf bis Fünfzehnjährigen, beziehungsweise eigentlich bis Zwölf-bis Siebzehnjährigen äh so ist.
Und ich denke, man kann das im Wesentlichen so zusammenfassen mit ja, nee, lass mal. Äh es sei denn Vorerkrankungen,
Klingt jetzt erst mal so ein bisschen ignorant. Ähm allerdings ähm,
heißt es ja immer erstmal, okay, das ist jetzt das, was wir jetzt denken. Das heißt nicht, dass wir äh unsere Meinung unter geänderten Rahmenbedingungen auch nochmal ändern können.
Das Ganze wurde schon die, also die haben sich da äh schon sehr ausführlich geäußert äh äh zu dem Thema und.
Ungewöhnlich deutlich auch geäußert zu dem.
Nämlich das äh ja sagen bei Kindern weder die Gefahr besteht, äh dass sie sterben.
In äh ja, äh wenn sie sich infizieren, noch.
Dass ja dieses dieses dass das zum Tode führt also das haben zwar gesagt ja tritt auf so vielleicht auch als Folge aber ist halt beherrschbar.
Und was bei äh Kindern angeht,
haben sie sich quasi eine Hintertür offen gelassen und gesagt, es gibt dazu noch nicht genug Daten, da muss man halt erstmal abwarten, äh so um.
Und ähm ja, äh ich meine und es wurde auch gemunkelt, dass sich die da jetzt nicht ganz einig war
aber man sich dann am Ende schon äh lieber auf diese deutliche klare äh Ansage geeinigt hat, die
ich im Kern auch für richtig halte äh muss ich äh sagen, also zumindest,
die Empfehlung, das was dabei rausgekommen ist, äh halte ich
ja für richtig und sinnvoll, weil man kann schon sagen, dass für über zwanzigjährige eine Impfung viel, viel mehr Nutzen entfaltet als für unter zwanzig Jährige, ja. Und das,
eben auch äh bei der ja Risikonutzen, Abwägung äh gewisse Unklarheiten,
bestehen,
man das durchaus so oder so sehen kann, was sich auch daran äußert, dass es in anderen Ländern Impfkommissionen gibt, die andere Empfehlungen äh äh geben als die STIKO.
Ähm und so bei begrenzten Impfstoff,
aber halte ich das für absolut richtig, dass man sagt, nee, wir geben keine generelle Impfempfehlung für gesunde Kinder und Jugendliche.
Was äh aber eben.
Umgekehrt bedeutet, äh dass es unter bestimmten Bedingungen dann doch sinnvoll und möglich äh ist oder sagen äh empfohlen wird. Zum einen gibt's eben die Empfehlung äh.
Für zwölf bis Siebzehnjährige mit bestimmten Vorerkrankungen. Da sagt die, ja, die sollen geimpft werden. Und äh
sagen äh und nach ärztlicher Aufklärung und bei individuellem Wunsch und der Risikoakzeptanz von Kindern, Jugendlichen oder ihren Eltern sei eine Immunisierung aber auch bei gesunden jungen Leuten
möglich, schreibt es RKI im Buletton. Was den Hintergrund hat, ähm dass es auch die Möglichkeit gibt, wenn zum Beispiel im.
Äh im Haus Angehörige leben, die vielleicht schwanger sind oder sonst wie nicht geimpft werden können oder anderweitig
Risiken ausgesetzt sind, dass man dann sagen kann, ja
auch wenn ja die Kinder im Haushalt sind zwar gesund aber wir möchten halt nicht dass sie das mit nach Hause bringen und dann die nicht impfbaren oder gefährdeten
des Haushalts anstecken. Das halte ich auch für sinnvoll. So, vor dem Hintergrund.
Sagen, ist das jetzt eine Regelung, äh die ich in Ordnung,
finde, einzige Problem ist halt noch bei den ganz kleinen, also wenn man dann Kinder im Kitaalter hat,
wird's dann im Moment eher noch nichts damit, das heißt im Zweifelsfall, wenn man dann in dieser Situation ist und jemand nicht impfbaren äh im Haushalt hat, ja
dann ähm gibt's dafür bei.
Kleinen Kindern eben unter oder Kindern unter zwölf eben noch keine Lösung, weil es da, glaube ich, noch nichts gibt, was zugelassen ist, wenn ich das richtig sehe in.
In Deutschland. Ja, aber da kann man hoffen, dass das halt bald auch kommt und äh ja.
Grundsätzlich äh besteht dann eben auch noch die Möglichkeit, dass.
Sich im irgendwann im Herbst oder im September ähm.
Ja auch nochmal die Zahlen verdichten, was so die Impfung Jugendlicher in anderen Ländern äh an.
Geht und auch äh die Varianten können da eben auch noch einiges ändern, so dass ich jetzt nicht davon ausgehe, dass diese Impfempfehlungen, so wie sie hier jetzt steht, für alle Zeit in Stein gemeißelt ist, sondern
dass wir da auch sicherlich äh spätestens im Herbst äh nochmal in Änderungen sehen werden. Ja, das.
Empfehlung.
Ja, ich finde, das äh hast du ganz treffend zusammengefasst. Gab verschiedene Leute, die berichtet haben, dass sie versucht haben, Impftermine für ihre Kinder zu bekommen und dann bei ihren Ärzten gescheitert sind, weil die gesagt haben, nein, die empfiehlt das ja nicht, deswegen machen wir das jetzt auch nicht.
Impfzentren allerdings, machen das, soweit ich das weiß, also,
bei denen, wo ich jetzt äh Einblick gewonnen habe, wenn man da einen Termin sich klickt, dann äh kann man auch davon ausgehen, dass es das gibt. Es gibt dann wohl in den Impfzentren für Kinder aber auch
Kinderärzte, also es fällt dann wirklich auch explizit von Kinderärzten geimpft, beziehungsweise die Kinderärzte.
Haben dann vielleicht auch mehr Übungen, ne, in der Ansprache äh der der Kinder,
und ähm so sollte das dann äh geregelt sein.
Ich denke, wenn die Kinder das wollen, ist ja auch äh wenn man diese ganze Empfehlungsgeschichte ist, so ein bisschen wieder so über die Kinder hinweg, ne, weil wir reden ja jetzt hier auch nicht so von von Todd an. Wir reden ja jetzt nicht von so äh,
Hosen.
Eigentlich von von jungen Erwachsenen, die irgendwie religionsmündig sind und äh ja, zum Teil und.
Schon, die dürfen auch schon irgendwie online Sachen kaufen und irgendwie Geld ausgeben, die äh und an denen geht diese Debatte auch nicht vorbei. Und wenn die dann sagen, ja, ich will aber auch geschützt werden.
Go go for it, ne. Gut. Ähm gucken wir mal so ein bisschen, was sonst noch so äh passiert.
Ähm es passiert viel im Bereich äh der ganzen,
Impfkampagne und ich hab's schon angedeutet, beziehungsweise dürfte das ja auch schon gehört haben
Äh läuft grad nicht so gut. Also, alle scheinen grade irgendwie einen schlechten Tag zu haben oder zumindest ähm nicht so hochformen auslaufen zu können.
Die äh Liste von verhältnismäßig schlechten Nachrichten wurde, glaube ich, von Johnson und Johnson
angeführt. Die mussten nämlich,
extremer Produktionsprobleme einräumen. Die hatten, ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, hast du mitbekommen, was da eigentlich schiefgelaufen ist? Ich habe verschiedene Sachen gehört, dass da irgendwie Verwechslungen aufgetreten sind oder generell
Problemen bei der Produktion.
Das Krasseste, was ich gehört habe, war, dass dort in einer Fabrik äh halt Zutaten, die eigentlich für
vorgesehen äh waren halt äh ja
in den falschen Impfstoff eingegangen sind. Also bei Johnson und Johnson in
in die Fertigung gegangen sind, um welche Stoffe es sich da handeln soll und ob das jetzt tatsächlich auch stimmt, weiß ich nicht. Das kann natürlich von Hilfsstoffen über äh ja irgendwie
weiß ich nicht, kann alles sein, ja. Ähm.
Und insofern, ja, unklar, aber äh zumindest, ich meine, der Fakt, dass es sich um sechzig Millionen Dosen handelt,
dass es jetzt nicht eine Charge, sondern das deutet auf jeden Fall darauf hin, dass das Produktionsproblem über längere Zeit bestanden.
Und jetzt nicht irgendwie ein Arbeiter irgendwo mal den falschen Knopf gedrückt hat äh oder so, sondern das muss irgendwo auf höherer Ebene passiert
sein, dass man das irgendwie falsch eingestellt eingerichtet oder wie auch immer Zutatenliste, 'nen Fehler hatte irgendwo
äh irgendwie sowas und keiner hat's gemerkt.
Immerhin haben sie's gemerkt. Äh danach ist ja auch gut. Besser als nie,
da sieht man auch immer wieder, dass das diese ganze Impfstoffproduktion ja auch eine erheblichen Qualitätskontrolle unterworfen sein muss und auch äh ist.
Ja, das Ganze war äh das Problem ist in USA aufgetreten, die haben da eine Produktionsstätte in Baltimore, da lief's wohl nicht so gut und ähm ja, das bedeutet, dass auch sechs Komma fünf Millionen Impfdosen, die uns erreichen sollten, in Quartal zwei äh voraussichtlich dann eben
wegfallen werden. Sprich, die Hoffnung auf Entlastung der Impfkampagne durch Johnson und Johnson im.
In diesem Quartal oder im nächsten Quartal, was gerade nichts. Zweites Quartal, drittes Quartal auf jeden Fall in der nächsten Zeit. Ähm ja, wird sich nicht bewahrheiten. Ja, also eigentlich war da eine deutliche Steigerung
Lieferungszahl äh angedacht und das wird jetzt irgendwie nicht stattfinden.
Beziehungsweise findet, glaube ich, grade nicht statt. Also Q zwei anders die sechs Komma fünf Millionen. Und wer weiß, was dann in Q3 noch fehlen wird.
Genau, der Q zwei ist ja jetzt auch gleich zu Ende, also das äh glaube nicht, dass jetzt wirklich noch sechs Komma fünf Millionen, vielleicht war das jetzt auch EU, ich bin mir gerade nicht ganz so sicher, vielleicht habe ich mir nicht richtig notiert. Auf jeden Fall kommt erstmal nix.
Ja. Ja, dürfte EU gewesen sein, na ja, das äh.
Dann gibt's auch noch Probleme bei Bier und Tech. Hier unser Klassenprimus, wobei das, glaube ich, so ein bisschen auch eine wieder so eine Fehlkommunikation war. Also wir hatten das ja schon, dass
Björn Tech gesagt hat, so jetzt kommt erstmal hier eine halbe Million pro Woche weniger, das schieben wir dann aber in den Juni rein
soweit so gut, aber dann ähm.
War's wohl so, dass insgesamt auch mehr geliefert wurde, aber das eben das jetzt nicht bedeutet, dass man dann,
die Lieferzahlen von Q3, die ursprünglich avisiert waren, auch halten können, weil man eben in Q zwei schon mehr geliefert hat
So, das war, glaube ich, so ein bisschen so die Hoffnung, dass das quasi nur mehr Produktion war und das irgendwie da mehr bei rauskam und äh die hohen Zahlen für den Juli gehalten werden können
ist es aber eher so, dass es eben nur eine frühere Lieferung war, aber das eben für Deutschland zumindest
nicht sehr viel mehr im Juli kommt, als man sich jetzt hätte ausrechnen können, wenn man Juli und Juni zusammennimmt. Die ganzen
ansagen, was jetzt wirklich kommt, das ist äh beim RKI dermaßen schlecht kommuniziert, da sind's wieder so
Excel Tabellen, in PDF, gedruckt, auf der Webseite und dann auch gleich noch mehrere mit irgendwie vollkommen unklaren Überschriften, wo man dann überhaupt nicht mehr weiß, was man jetzt eigentlich zusammenziehen muss oder nicht
Von daher war das eh immer schon die ganze Zeit etwas schwammig, was kommt, aber das ist jetzt zumindest eben das Problem bei.
Biotech, was nicht wirklich ein Problem ist, also das einzige Problem ist halt, wer hätte gerne mehr davon, aber gibt's nicht.
Moderner
nicht gut, habe ich vorhin schon erwähnt, also da sind dann mal in der Woche äh fünfhunderttausend ausgefallen, also irgendwie fünfhundertfünfzigtausend waren wohl irgendwie angesagt und ähm ja, das kam halt irgendwie nicht an.
Letzte Woche lief's dann aber dann wieder, das kann sein, dass es nur so eine einmalige Geschichte war, naja.
Aber auch das hilft uns gerade nicht wirklich weiter. Ja, Moderner war das einzige, was eigentlich konstant äh geliefert hat und ähm das hat jetzt äh auch nicht funktioniert.
Ja und Asra bleibt halt ohnehin
Das haben wir auch schon angesprochen, so ein bisschen so ein Ladenhüter. Also auf der einen Seite gab's ja immer schon diese Versprechen mit, es kommt ganz viel und derzeit gilt das irgendwie alles nicht mehr so richtig, ist sehr schwierig damit zu
planen. Ähm es gibt auch überhaupt gar keine äh langfristigen Prognosen, wie viel von Asra Sindika noch kommt. Auf der einen Seite, ne?
Der anderen Seite haben wir eben dieses Nachfrageproblem, was wohl auch schon dazu führt, dass also viele Dosen dann,
am Ende überhaupt gar keinen Arm erreichen, weil die halt irgendwo hingeliefert wurden, wo es dann keine Abnehmer dafür gibt, das ist natürlich immer auch besonders dramatisch, finde ich.
Naja und dann eben schon das diskutierte Umlegen von Zweitimpfungen auf äh Bier und Tech oder moderner. Also derzeit scheint das so ein bisschen so ein Ladenhüter zu sein. Es gibt zwar immer mal wieder erfolgreiche Kampagnen, wo gesagt wird, hier zack nimmt es und dann ähm
gibt's auch genug Interessenten. Also grundsätzlich denke ich, könnte man's schon an Frauenmann äh bringen. Es ist halt nur eben immer die Frage, wo in welcher Situation, mit welcher Strategie.
Also da würde, wie schon gesagt haben, wahrscheinlich helfen, wenn man die Kombi im Funk äh anbieten oder empfehlen äh äh würde.
Könnte man wahrscheinlich vermeiden so viele Dosen dann wegzuwerfen von von Astra.
Genau. Also es wäre auch mal eine positive Geschichte, die man mal erzählen kann, ne. Und ich denke in dieser ganzen äh Sache wird einfach zu wenig mit positiven Geschichten gearbeitet.
Ja und wie ihr auch schon gesagt haben, äh wenn man an eine Impfung mit Astra jetzt schnell rankommen kann.
Kann man
letztlich äh auch äh selbst äh diese Kombiimpfung wählen, weil äh nur weil man eine erste Impfung mit Astrasinika hat, heißt das nicht, äh dass man sich nicht die Zweitimpfung dann äh mit äh Bayern Tech äh.
Oder mit einem anderen M RNA Impfstoff äh geben lassen kann, so dass funktioniert.
In der Regel problemlos, äh so wie ich das äh mitbekommen habe.
Wie du so schon das letzte Mal gesagt hast, man kann ja nicht dazu gezwungen werden.
Eine zweite Dosis zu nehmen und äh am Ende äh ja bei den Impfzentren, die wollen halt äh einfach impfen äh so äh wie du schon so richtig gesagt hast, die.
Haben jetzt nicht das Ziel irgendwie jetzt Leute einer Inquisition zu unterziehen und so und wenn man halt,
dann den entsprechenden Abstand einhält dann ist das halt in der Regel unproblematisch.
So, aber jetzt haben wir ein neues äh Problemkind. Und das ist äh in der Tat eine etwas ähm ja dramatische, tragische Geschichte, finde ich bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Nämlich.
Ähm zur Erinnerung, auch ein deutsches Unternehmen, ähm vor allem dadurch, dass der äh.
Von der SAP äh da viel Geld reingesteckt hat ähm so bekannt geworden.
Und was darf man auch nicht vergessen, der Mensch, der Tour weg gegründet hat, Ingmar Höhr, der.
Das ist auch derjenige, der im Prinzip das erste Mal,
gesagt hat und dann auch den Beweis angetreten hat, dass dass du so eine dieser Transportweg über MRNA doch vielleicht mal eine feine Idee wäre. Das ist in Tübingen,
passiert und äh liegt jetzt mehr als zwanzig Jahre zurück. Das war so ein bisschen sein Moment.
Und ja, das Unternehmen hat dann eben lange, lange Zeit darauf hingearbeitet, in irgendeiner Form auf dem Markt zu bestehen, haben wir auch, glaube ich, schon mal hier diskutiert,
alles nicht so einfach, sind mit verhältnismäßig wenig Geld haben die sich dann über zwei Jahrzehnte eben durchgenudelt,
Ja, dann kommt die Pandemie und auf einmal schreien alle Impfstoffe, Impfstoffe, Impfstoffe und äh natürlich weiß auch äh der Chef von Kurvek, dass das jetzt unter Umständen der Moment ist, wo äh die die große Prüfung ansteht.
Genau zu diesem Zeitpunkt erleidet eben dieser Ingmar Hör eine Gehirnblutung und fällt halt irgendwie aus. Also das ist gerade zum Vorstandschef
berufen worden und äh fällt dann sozusagen aus. Und äh verliert zu Unzeit ganz wichtige Zeit.
Dann äh gab's halt diese Aufregung, dann angeblich wollte ja Trump kaufen und all so eine Geschichten, ob das überhaupt stimmt, das äh ist nochmal eine andere Sache. Auf jeden Fall war die Bundesrepublik dann
sehr erpicht dadrauf, das äh zu verhindern, wenn's auch nur ansatzweise stimmt, ist dann im Juni,
äh über die KfW mit dreiundzwanzig Prozent in dem Unternehmen eingestiegen, gab dann entsprechend auch noch Förderungsgelder, nochmal zweihundertfünfzig Millionen
dann ist man an die Börse gegangen im August, das lief super, da ging irgendwie die Zahlen innerhalb von,
kürzester Zeit auf zweihundertfünfzig Prozent vom Ausgabepreis hoch. Und äh gute Nachrichten,
dann auch noch äh nicht zuletzt deshalb, weil es ja auch noch diese Kooperation mit Tesla gab, also deswegen mit Tesla, nicht wegen der Autos, sondern wegen,
Unternehmens Gromann, was Tesla gekauft hat. Automation, was halt so Automatisierungstechnik baut, einerseits eben für.
Die Automobilproduktion, aber eben auch im medizinischen Bereich
dieser RNA-Printer, an den äh forscht, dass es dann sozusagen so ein Teil. Also das waren so die positiven Storys und vor allem hat man äh damit gerechnet
dass eben auch jetzt irgendwann mal dieser Impfstoff kommt und seit Monaten wird darüber diskutiert, dass dieser Impfstoff doch im Prinzip bald mal zugelassen werden müsste. Und vor allem haben alle erwartet,
dass dieser Impfstoff gute Ergebnisse erzielt, vergleichbar mit Bier und Tech und mit moderner, weil er ja letzten Endes exakt dieselbe Formulierung
beinhaltet, also wenn ich richtig informiert bin, ist tatsächlich diese RNA-Beschreibung in dem Impfstoff dieselbe.
Wie in äh Björn Tech und Boom bei moderner.
Und weiß nicht, wenn dann nur mit marginalen äh Abweichungen. Ja, aber stellt sich raus, jetzt musste Kurve ähm eine.
Vorabmeldung machen und muss mal so Zwischenergebnisse liefern und sieht so aus, als ob die Wirkung
erzielte Wirkung in dieser Phase drei Tests, die durchgeführt worden sind in den letzten Monaten, nur bei siebenundvierzig Prozent liegt.
Also mal so locker die Hälfte von dem, was wir bei Bier und Tisch und bei moderner gesehen haben, ne.
Ja. Mhm.
Bisschen mehr als die Hälfte.
Also in der, in der Pressemeldung jetzt, das Haus sogar bei Reuters steht's jetzt von heute, ist noch relativ.
Frisch äh und sagen, äh dass äh,
dieses Gerücht, was rumging, das ist wohl wegen der zu niedrigen Dosis äh äh ist, stammt wohl von äh Peter Krempsner,
aus Tübingen
äh der äh sagen, mit dem Versuch, betraut war wohl, also äh sagen, von einem der Betreuenden, ja, Forscher äh und insofern äh ja
Theorie an der Stelle und dort im Artikel steht zumindest auch noch, dass sie halt.
Eben doch 'ne andere genommen haben und die nicht modifiziert
haben, also irgendwelche Modifikationen, die Bayerntechnik und moderner durchgeführt haben, hat wohl nicht gemacht und die,
sollen wohl dazu geführt haben, dass äh sie die Dosis niedrig halten mussten, weil äh sonst,
einfach die Leute zu viele Beschwerden gehabt haben, wenn sie die die Dosis erhöht haben und so haben sie halt den Test jetzt net wohl mit zwölf Mikrogramm.
MRNA Pro Dosis äh ähm geimpft so in der Hoffnung auch eine Niedrigdosis Alternative.
Äh zu sein. Ähm während halt Bio und Hech mit dreißig und moderner mit hundert Mikrogramm wohl pro Schott äh ran,
geht. Äh insofern äh ja denke ich.
Kann das tatsächlich was damit zu tun haben und das Problem wenn dem so ist, ist dass sie dann halt zumindest damit jetzt mit diesem Impfstoff auch die Dosis nicht einfach erhöhen können oder irgendwie wahrscheinlich,
auch nichts anderes machen können,
dann äh einfach mit einem neuen Impfstoff an den Staat zu gehen und äh ja.
Das äh ist natürlich nicht gut. So. Vor allen Dingen natürlich.
Der Zeitverlust so war ja schon problematisch, weil wenn du dann einen Impfstoff hast, der eben sich,
bewährt hat, der viele Millionen Male verimpft worden ist, wo man weiß, was er kann und was er nicht kann,
ähm und wo die Probleme liegen, hat man natürlich mit einem neuen Impfstoff, der muss dann natürlich,
irgendwie besser sein, weil wenn der muss dann irgendwelche spezifischen Vorteile auf jeden Fall haben und ja, selbst wenn wenn sie jetzt im Prinzip,
oder moderner Nachmachen.
Sagen fehlt dann natürlich irgendwo der Vorteil so haben wir natürlich Bayern Tech und Moderner die Produktion auch optimiert und,
und, und, und haben natürlich viel mehr Erfahrung und die Produktionskapazitäten und das ist dann so.
Als wollte man irgendwie als dritte oder vierte Suchmaschine äh an den Start gehen. Äh.
Gut, muss man mal sehen, ne? Also wie sich das äh jetzt auskenßt. Also ich denke, ähm äh da kann jetzt irgendwie alles,
passieren. Man man kann sich ja sowieso fragen, was jetzt eigentlich so die Qualität dadrin ist, dass wir in Deutschland noch so ein zweites äh äh
Unternehmen haben, was im Prinzip versucht nochmal dasselbe in grün zu bauen. Klar, das sind so die Gründer und die hatten so ihre eigenen Ideen und sie hatten auch andere Designziele
ja, die ihr vielleicht auch ein Problem äh waren, dass sie von
vorne rein gesagt haben, ja, unser äh im Schloss war halt supergeil sein und soll irgendwie bei niedriger Kühlung funktionieren et cetera
gesagt hat, ja, Kühlung kriegt man irgendwie hin, es war ein Problem, aber Hauptsache, das Ding funktioniert erstmal. Und später gucken wir dann mal, was äh wie gut das eigentlich wirklich hält,
genau das haben sie ja gemacht und mittlerweile sind sie da eben auch bei sehr viel höheren Temperaturen angelangt, sodass man eben sagen kann, ja okay, Bayerntech hält jetzt auch,
genug, um das irgendwie auch noch ein, zwei Wochen vorhalten zu können bei einer Arztpraxis,
Von daher sind das quasi marginale Probleme, insbesondere in der Pandemie
wo, na, wo das alles schnell weggeimpft wird, ne? Klar, wir haben natürlich jetzt auch Länder, wo das dann eben so ein Problem ist, aber,
Letzten Endes haben sie ja dieses Ziel erreicht ohne sich zu sehr auf dieses Ziel zu fixieren,
Mal gucken, ob die Firma Küweck das überlebt. Mich würde es auch nicht wundern, wenn wir jetzt sehen, dass BioTech die einfach kauft.
Die Leute können sie sicherlich gebrauchen und äh wenn wenn die sich dann alle darum kümmern, noch mehr von dem anderen Impfstoff zu erzeugen, ist ja irgendwie auch gut, ne?
Keine Ahnung. Ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen ignorant von mir, aber ähm.
Ich mache mir um die Arbeitsplätze jetzt ehrlich gesagt keine Sorgen. Das sind alle Leute, die da arbeiten, die werden so oder so gebraucht werden. Die Frage ist nur, welches Labelklebt da oben drauf.
Gute Nachrichten gibt's allerdings aus den USA, denn es gibt ja auch noch einen,
weiteren Impfstoffkandidaten und der könnte tatsächlich die Landschaft nochmal äh auf eine interessante Art und Weise bereichern. Nämlich der Impfstoff der Firma Novax.
War ja schon immer irgendwie auf der Liste. Es gibt jetzt hier auch noch keine klaren Lieferprognosen, weil glaub ich die Verhandlungen da mit der EU noch ein bisschen zäh laufen.
Aber davon auszugehen, dass es dann auch am Ende Deutschland erreicht. Wird allerdings noch ein bisschen dauern. Ist eher so eine Sache für den Herbst,
Was ist das Besondere daran? Also der Nova-Wax-Impfstoff ist halt jetzt der erste auf Proteinbasis.
Vielleicht noch mal so zur Erinnerung, um das einordnen zu können. Derzeit haben wir es eigentlich im Wesentlichen mit.
Drei Arten von Bagazinen zu tun, in Deutschland eigentlich nur zwei davon. Ne, wir haben diese Astrasinika ähm,
Johnson und Johnson Kategorie, wo auch noch Sputnik V miteinzurechnen ist,
Vektorvirus. Da wird also diese Information, die dieses Spike Protein, das Virus beschreibt, in DNA abgelegt. Der Virus wird.
Geimpft, dringt in die Zelle ein,
In der Zelle wird diese DNA in RNA abgeschrieben und die RNA wiederum erzeugt dann halt dieses Bike Protein und dann kommt das Immunsystem und sagt, okay, alles klar, so sieht das aus, merke ich mir.
Impfstoffe bei und ähm theoretisch eben auch Kurve und natürlich moderner. Die überspringen quasi diesen Schritt mit der,
mit dem Zellkern, gehen geben einfach diese fertige vorher schon fertige,
RNA direkt in die Zelle, in dieses Zytoplasma und fängt sofort mit der Produktion an.
Das verhindert dann unter anderem diese Komplikationen, die wir ja schon mal beschrieben haben beim Abschreiben, ne, was ja so ein bisschen so ein,
im Verdacht steht für die Komplikationen von äh ähm und Johnson und Johnson mit den Thrombosen verantwortlich zu sein
weil's eben beim Abschreiben die Freiheit gibt, für den Körper auch mal falsch abzuschreiben,
Das entfällt natürlich in dem Moment, wenn man quasi das den Abschieb schon direkt in den Körper einschleust und dann kann's vielleicht immer noch was schief gehen, aber es ist schon mal eine Fehlerquelle,
weniger.
Das äh ist klar, das ist alles sehr erfolgreich. Jetzt gibt's aber noch einen dritten äh ach so, dann was ich, was wir in Deutschland nicht haben, das ist das, was ich mit dem dritten Mal sind, halt so diese äh chinesischen Impfstoffe.
Die ähm halt also wirklich mit dem Kopf zwei Virus arbeiten, denen irgendwie dis eben, also diese Totimpfstoffe, die jetzt aber auch nicht so geile
Ergebnisse erzielen. Äh das zeigt sich zum Beispiel gerade in Chile, die ja irgendwie eine super erfolgreiche Impfkampagne hatten, was die reinen Zahlen betrifft. Trotzdem gehen die Inzidenzen.
Gerade durch die Decke in Chile sind die Intensivstationen wieder voll. Es ist wieder alles so richtig schön müllig. Und es werden halt auch viele Leute
infiziert, die halt schon geimpft worden sind. Einfach weil die äh Wirksamkeit von Sinovak einfach nicht so gut ist.
Das zeigt sich dort.
Ja, nicht nur, nicht nur dort, sondern äh in Indonesien äh.
Ist, haben sich wohl äh hunderte von Ärzten und medizinischen Personal
dreihundert von dreihundertfünfzig Ärzten und Medical Workers ist die Rede, die in Indonesien trotz Sinovak, Impfung sich infiziert haben,
und äh einige Dutzend davon äh sogar mussten hospitalisiert äh werden.
Und die Vermutung war jetzt auch, dass das was mit Varianten äh zu tun.
So also äh vermutlich äh war's die Deltavariante, die da äh ja.
Sinowak wohl aus dem Tritt gebracht hat.
Die P eins Variante im Übrigen. Also, wie heißt das Ding Gamma? Genau.
Ja. Also insofern, ja,
hoffen, ähm dass so die Impfstoffe, die wir jetzt dann verimpfen, äh da nicht so sehr schwächeln und vieles deutet ja darauf hin, dass zumindest so unsere MRA Impfstoffe da.
Noch ganz gut helfen, aber ja.
So sieht's aus. Genau. Also wir haben jetzt diese ganzen Methoden, ja.
Beiden, die halt irgendwie übern Zeltern äh gehen, also die
chinesischen Impfstoffe und die Vektor-Impfstoffe dann halt direkt RNA. Das ist halt dann die äh Biotech äh Abteilung. Und jetzt kommt halt noch ein Protein,
Impfstoff dazu. Und das ist im Prinzip, da überspringt man diesen letzten Schritt auch noch,
und liefert dem Körper einfach direkt dieses Spike Protein, das Virus oder genau genommen sind's, glaube ich, Bruchstücke davon.
Sprich, man hat einfach diese Proteine nachgezüchtet in großen Mengen und dann
müssen die sehr aufwendig gereinigt werden, das ist so 'n relativ komplexer Vorgang, vielleicht erinnert ihr euch auch noch hier an diesen Fall von diesem etwas wirren.
Ähm Virologen da aus Rostock, der ein bisschen auffällig geworden ist, weil
Die ganze Zeit die Fernsehteams zu sich gelockt hat und erzählt hat, er würde ja jetzt hier irgendwie den geilsten Impfstoff der ganzen Welt machen und keiner würde ihn ja fördern. Er ist dann auch gleich wieder,
sich da sozusagen von äh problematischen Bevölkerungsgruppen äh abfeiern lassen. Am Ende war das auch nichts anderes als der, ich habe mal einen Protein gemacht.
Aber der schwierige Prozess ist, dass eben dann auch in Phase drei Studien zu belegen und das irgendwie weltweit auszurollen und entsprechend zu kontrollieren. Dafür braucht man einfach die Kooperation eines großen Unternehmens. Oder man ist halt schon ein großes Unternehmen.
Das ist jetzt das, was Novaks mit äh,
Einbringt. Also der Novaks Impfstoff ist ein Protein Impfstoff. Man hat quasi Teile dieses Spike Proteins nachgezüchtet mal so im salopp gesagt und dann kriegt man
Stückchen direkt geimpft, das heißt, der Körper sieht so, oh, was ist das denn hier äh in Truder Alert, ähm da reagiere ich jetzt mal drauf.
Natürlich nur die halbe Geschichte, weil man kennt das schon bei solchen Impfstoffen.
Würde man jetzt tatsächlich nur diese Proteinbestandteile impfen, würde es der Körper wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal merken.
Würde wahrscheinlich eher na ja.
Das würde dann halt so irgendwie rumfliessen, aber nur Teile des Körpers würden darauf reagieren. Und deswegen wird in solchen Impfstoffen
sogenannte noch mit dazugegeben, also irgendwelche Wirkstoffe, die dann eben so bewusst so eine Reizung des Körpers hervorrufen, so.
Früher war das irgendwie so Aluminium ähm oder was dann das Aluminium,
und äh andere äh Sachen, die sozusagen.
Den Körper schon mal so ein bisschen ankratzen und sagen so, ah, hier ist irgendwas, äh hier ist irgendwas faul.
Wirf mal deinen Apparat an und dann so äh werden dann eben auch die anderen Bestandteile äh bemerkt und also was das denn, was liegt denn hier rum? Na, da baue ich dann gleich mal Antikörper gegen auf.
Klingt erst mal so, als würde das nicht gut funktionieren können.
Aber funktioniert tatsächlich wohl ganz gut, denn die Phase drei Studien bei Novaks sagen, ist zu neunzig Prozent wirksam.
Aussage, in Klammern, Aussage des Herstellers. Ja, also wir haben jetzt nur einen Pressrelease äh des Herstellers. Diese Studien sind jetzt in dem Sinne noch nicht
veröffentlicht worden, weil das ist nur eine Vorabmeldung und man geht davon aus,
das Novax so Ende September den Prozess in den USA einleitet, um da eine Zulassung zu bekommen.
Ja. Ja, ähm sicherlich auch auch nicht verkehrt. Ähm.
Schicke halt an jetzt den Vektor, den RNA-Impfstoffen äh ist, dass sie halt eigentlich ohne Atviuantien äh auskommen. Und.
Ähm ja mit den.
War das irgendwie immer so eine so eine Sache äh so, weil ein Problem ist wohl auch, dass die selber gar nicht als Medikament, sondern als Hilfsstoff,
und äh klar, sicherlich, dass das Ganze dieser Impfstoff in in Gänze eben auch seine Wirksamkeit und seine Verträglichkeit.
Auf die Probe ähm stellen äh sollte, aber es gab halt zum Beispiel beim.
Berlin eben, was auch als neben jetzt Aluminium äh.
Verbindungen genutzt wurde und ja ist halt eigentlich auch ein körpereigener Stoff so der.
Auch eben, ja, im Körper natürlich vorkommt und.
Jetzt hatte man dann aber gesehen, dass bestimmte Bevölkerungsgruppen.
Antikörper gegen Squalin entwickelt haben, was halt irgendwie doof ist, weil es weil eben halt ein körpereigener Stoff ist, aber äh.
Ist jetzt wohl dann auch nicht wirklich so super schlimm, aber eben auch nicht, nicht ideal nur die Studienlage dazu zum Beispiel war eben sehr, sehr unübersichtlich, beziehungsweise sogar so, ich habe,
sich die dann mal auseinandergenommen habe, war halt klar, dass nicht alle Studien zugleich wahr sein können, die es zu dem Thema gibt. Also es gab da halt einfach.
Ja 'ne unklare
Studienlage dazu, insofern war ich jetzt dann so ein bisschen erfreut, dass man sich eben bei den anderen Impfstoffen nicht nochmal extra über das
nochmal Gedanken äh machen muss, was das denn vielleicht tut
So und die verwenden da wohl bei Wachs irgendwas Neues, was irgendwie den,
coolen Marketingnamen irgendwie, Matrix M, Matrix M eins, glaube ich, äh äh hat und äh im Prinzip,
auch was organisches äh ist, also genau hatte ich mir das jetzt nicht angeguckt.
Was das äh sein soll, aber klingt irgendwie so ein bisschen Porsche mäßig.
Zaponine nie gehört. Irgend so eine komische ähm irgendwas mit Chemie.
Na ja. Okay.
Kann man
drauf sein, aber ähm brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht den Atem anzuhalten, denn äh ja, wie gesagt, also Ende äh Ende September in den USA bedeutet, das wird jetzt auch sehr viel schneller nicht hier ähm stattfinden. Aber ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass die Bemühungen jetzt den zu bekommen.
Ähm nochmal angeheizt werden durch die Probleme mit all den anderen, die wir hier schon erwähnt haben. Und äh vielleicht ist das eben dann was für Oktober, November, was weiß ich.
Ja. Ja. Gut und nur um's vielleicht auch nochmal klarzustellen, also äh.
Ich,
habe mich äh jetzt unter anderem auch vor zwei äh oder vor drei Wochen auch mit äh irgendwie äh anderen Impfstoffen, die Atjuvanzchen enthalten haben äh äh impfen lassen, ohne da jetzt großartig drüber nachzudenken.
Ähm aber äh ja grundsätzlich natürlich ähm ja äh möchte man natürlich schon.
Wissen, was man denn da gerade in den Kreislauf äh alles äh reingespritzt bekommt an Mitteln, das denke ich, ist jetzt,
äh ja auch nichts Verkehrtes äh sich darüber zu informieren.
Moderne hatten wir schon erwähnt, dass die Probleme hatten, kleinerer äh Natur, aber gibt auch gute Nachrichten oder finde ich zumindest, dass es erstmal ganz vielversprechende äh Aussichten sind, sagen wir es mal so.
Denn äh das hatten wir auch schon mal erwähnt, die Firma will ja jetzt nicht nur Corona bekämpfen, sondern ist ja auch nicht dafür gegründet worden
sondern bei moderner, das geht
natürlich auch für hat man ganz andere Ziele, ne? Über die Fähigkeiten von RNA Technologie haben wir ja auch schon viele Worte äh verloren, ne? Das ist eine ganze Menge Potenzial bereit, hält in verschiedener Hinsicht
Aber moderner ist auch schon dabei und ist äh dieses Jahr schon dabei.
Phase eins Tests durchzuführen, also diese klinischen.
Studien, wo man erstmal guckt so, OK, wir haben jetzt hier 'nen Impfstoff und jetzt wollen wir mal gucken
wie äh wir den anwenden, was wir da so für eine Dosierung brauchen. Ähm testet das mit Tieren und guckt halt einfach mal so.
Wie macht der sich jetzt eben äh konkret? Und bereitet dann eben Phase zwei und Phase drei Tests mit Menschen vor, um dann eben in Latschs Geld zu gucken, ob man damit entsprechende Ergebnisse erzielt. Jetzt geht's aber nicht um Corona
sondern tatsächlich hat äh moderner drei verschiedene äh Waxine hier ähm,
Also in der in der Untersuchung und ähm einer ist für HIV.
Einer ist für die Grippe.
Und ähm dann auch noch gibt's und das ist, glaube ich, sogar schon ein bisschen weiter ähm,
noch ein ähm Impfstoff gegen den, wie heißt es, schön, Zytomegalo Virus.
Ähm jetzt habe ich wieder vergessen, was das ist. Ähm Herpes.
Wie ah.
Der Herpes Art.
Genau. Ähm konkret sind sogar vier Impfstoffe, weil bei HIV probiert man zwei aus, ne, also einer gegen Grippe, einer gegen ähm Herpes äh.
Und sogar noch einer gegen RSV. Das äh habe ich letztes Mal schon nicht herausbekommen, was es ist, weil er ist vor so viele Abkürzungen hat, dass ich's äh vergessen habe. Also hier ist äh respiritory Sinn,
Na, egal.
Auf jeden Fall sind die gut unterwegs. Das wollte ich jetzt äh damit sagen und weißer Geier, vielleicht funktioniert das ja das Zeug. Und ähm,
dann,
könnten wir auf einmal mit einem neuen Impfstoff gegen die Grippe dastehen. Wir könnten mit einem Impfstoff gegen HIV dastehen. Das sind alles Durchbrüche, ne. Also man hat
gerade im Grippebereich ja noch äh eine Menge Verbesserungspotential, weil so die aktuellen äh Wirksamkeiten von den ähm Grippeimpfstoffen, die halt so bei vierzig bis sechzig Prozent
und moderner scheint wohl recht zuversichtlich zu sein, das deutlich zu steigern und dann eben auch die Produktion äh auch natürlich auf eine ganz andere technologische Basis zu stellen.
Ja. Und das wäre natürlich.
Super cool, wenn sie quasi ja auch die Produktionszeiten dann verkürzen könnten, wie auch äh immer und dann.
Sagen, gucken äh
dann quasi just in time äh Impfstoffe produzieren, je nachdem wie sie sehen, welche Varianten sich da gerade ausbreiten. Das wäre natürlich so als Endziel natürlich super geil, wenn man
gleich ja Impfstoffe gegen gegen spezifische Varianten äh da bauen kann, zeitnah.
Gut, kommen wir wieder zurück zu äh Corona. Und ich glaube, wir können an dieser Stelle auch mal noch eine andere persönliche Information streuen, weil da haben wir jetzt bissel bisher uns auch noch nicht so drüber ausgelassen. Äh wenn ich das richtig sehe, haben wir jetzt beide
auch eine Zweitimpfung abbekommen, oder? Hast du dich nicht heute auch äh vervollständig.
Hier habe ich in der Tat.
Du bist noch in der Lage, einen Podcast aufzunehmen. So schlimm kannst du also nicht gekommen sein.
Also tatsächlich ähm merke ich jetzt nichts außer vielleicht verhindert ich das Gefühl, dass ich
vielleicht etwas leise gesprochen äh oder etwas sehr langsam gesprochen habe und etwas sehr monoton,
was aber auch mit der Temperatur zusammenhängen könnte und dass ich das Fenster zuhabe damit nicht zu viele Nebengeräusche.
Reinkommen. Sowas tut man nicht alles für Corona wie.
Selbstversuch sozusagen.
Genau und äh ja und ich habe äh wie du auch die sagen äh Astra äh.
Und äh MRNA Kombi Impfung äh so erhalten und äh ja der erste Astraschott hatte ich ein bisschen was gemerkt.
Hatte so, ich glaube am,
am Abend etwas erhöhte äh Temperatur, aber Fieber würde ich das nicht nennen, sondern nur gemerkt, ja, Immunsystem arbeitet,
und dann eben so zwei Tage lang so den der Arm äh wenn man ihn angefasst hat, spürte man.
Etwas und äh ja, jetzt so heute.
Habe ich noch nicht mal so richtig, also ich muss muss da schon richtig auf die Stelle drauf drücken, damit ich überhaupt irgendwas merke, also minimale Reaktion an der Einstichstelle, würde ich sagen, äh bis bisher.
Du gingst mir auch, ja.
Ja ähm insofern, ich meine das äh heißt jetzt nicht, dass es jedem äh so ergeht oder ergehen.
Muss äh so und das muss auch nicht gut sein. So
äh wenn man aber ich kann mich eigentlich nie erinnern, äh wirklich äh auf auf Impfungen, auch als als Kind
oder so irgendwie besonders reagiert zu haben so. Das war irgendwie so ja keine Ahnung,
Schluck runter damals, weil sie nach Schluckimpfung oder dann andere Impfungen so, ja, Peaks.
Das war dann eigentlich immer alles, aber sofern.
Ich habe genau die gleiche Malage, also es ist,
äh exakt genauso. Ich habe auch noch nie von irgendeiner Impfung was gemerkt und ich äh wundere mich immer so, wenn alle anderen mir berichten, dass sie sich mal hinlegen mussten, müde waren, was weiß ich. Ich war nicht nur nicht müde, ich äh konnte problemlos bis nachts um drei irgendwie noch weiter im Internet rumklicken und komplett vergessen, dass ich überhaupt eine
Erstimpfung bekommen habe und die Zweitimpfung war jetzt im Prinzip noch langweiliger als die erste. Also von daher, ich würde ja, hätte ja gerne von irgendwelchen.
Wilden Kämpfen mit meinem Immunsystem äh berichtet und äh danach wieder äh mich besser zu fühlen, aber das ist es halt einfach nicht.
Nee und ich und ich hatte ja dann noch zwischen der Erste und Zweitimpfung äh noch
zwei weitere Impfungen äh so mit äh irgendwie Kombiimpfungen gegen insgesamt fünf verschiedene Krankheiten so. Habe ich jetzt auch nicht viel von mir
Eine in den linken und einen in den rechten Arm und äh ja.
Sieht's aus. Ähm tja als das dann durch war.
Dachte ich mir so, okay, jetzt kann man auch mal diesen digitalen Impfpass ausprobieren.
Und dann war das ja letzten Montag soweit und hab das dann einfach mal aus Interesse gemacht, nichts ich der Meinung bin, dass ich das jetzt irgendwie,
benötigen würde oder so, aber ich wollte einfach mal diesen Prozess äh machen. Denn in der Zwischenzeit sind halt äh entsprechende Updates gekommen,
Für die Corona-Warn-App beziehungsweise das Release der sogenannten App, da sind also jetzt so zwei Apps, genau genommen sind's drei. Es gibt auch noch eine Check.
Also es gibt eine, die hält diesen Impfpass. Es gibt eine, die checkt diesen Impfpass, wenn man also anderer Leute Impfpässe überprüfen möchte, kann man diese Check-App nehmen und
ansonsten hat man halt diese Kopfpassapp, aber man kann's genauso gut einfach direkt in die Corona-Warn-App
äh rein importieren. Das ist auch irgendwie kein großes Ding im Wesentlichen machen die nicht sehr viel anderes als ein QR-Code zu lesen, ähm halbwegs so Interpri
und zu verifizieren, um ihn dann gleich wieder anzuzeigen.
Ähm ich habe das dann bei einer Apotheke machen lassen, weil das Impfzentrum, wo ich war.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt, als ich die Zweitimpfung bekommen habe, war das äh noch nicht aktiv. Äh hätte jetzt nachgeholt werden können. Hatst du das schon?
Ja, heute war es aktiv so, da saßen irgendwie dann am Ausgang, also wurde man dann dirigiert, soweit zwei Impfung saßen dann da irgendwie zehn Bundeswehrsoldaten.
In so einem Rondell und haben einem dann äh dieses äh Zertifikat ausgedruckt,
und äh überreicht zusammen mit
irgendwie noch drei Merkblättern äh wo drin steht äh was man da machen kann und äh soll, aber es war wirklich so trivial. Ich habe irgendwie einfach die, ja, die CBA äh.
Äh
Datet und ähm wie denn ja den richtigen Knopf gefunden, draufgehalten, Ben äh war's da und äh ja ähm.
Und jetzt muss ich noch zwei Wochen warten, bis es grün wird.
Klar. Ähm so, ja, was
Die Frage ist natürlich jetzt, was, was, was hat man ich jetzt davon, ne? Und ähm das ist natürlich so eine Frage. Also erstmal, was ich
äh äh ach so, kurze Nachfrage, ist aber nicht so, dass jetzt die Bundeswehrsoldaten da jetzt von dir noch mal den Impfpass genommen hätten und die nochmal neu eingetippt hätten, um dieses Ding zu erzeugen. Das lag da schon rum sozusagen. Und
der richtige Zettel rausgeholt.
Die haben irgendwie, ich glaube nur, nur den mussten nur den Namen äh irgendwie nochmal eingeben oder irgendwas, aber nicht nochmal.
Nur die Daten raussuchen, quasi anhand deines Namens. Okay.
Das dachte ich mir schon. Äh alles andere macht ja keinen Sinn. Eine Apotheke muss das halt alles nochmal eingetippt werden. Und das erstaunliche ist und das gilt im Übrigen auch für entsprechende Generator-Webseiten, die es auch noch gibt. Es gibt eine Webseite
digitaler Impfnachweis, App und so, da kann man irgendwie seine Daten auch eingeben oder ist zumindest das Interface für die Apotheken auch.
Und naja, man gibt da halt nur einen Namen, ein Geburtsdatum ein, äh aber was zum Beispiel nicht erfasst wird, sind diese Chargennummern.
Nö.
Was so ein bisschen absurd äh mir vorkommt, ne, weil damit ist schon mal klar, dass diese digitale.
Informationen überhaupt nicht Äquivalent ist. Zu dem, was im Impfpass steht.
Ist nicht so, dass man sein Impfwasser dann irgendwie wegschmeißen könnte, als dann sollte man eh nicht tun so, ne? Aber ich hätte ja zumindest mal erwartet, dass mindestens diese geringe Informationsmenge dort sich auch nochmal abspielt.
Ja, aber.
Ja aber was.
Ich, ich finde also Datensparsamkeit, also für den für den Zweck, für den der jetzt gedacht ist, nämlich dass man seinen Impfpass nicht
in der Öffentlichkeit vorzeigen und rumschleppen muss und dass die Leute,
nicht reingucken müssen und irgendwie äh Handschrift entziffern und irgendwie mit Datum rechnen müssen, sondern einfach.
Klar. Ich habe ja auch nicht gesagt, dass diese Chargennummer jedem angezeigt werden soll,
Aber ich hätte zumindest erwartet, dass man sie eingibt und überprüft. Es gibt ja diese safe App vom RKI äh von, wo man, also vom Institut
wo man seine äh Wirkung, äh Impfreaktionen äh erfassen kann, da muss man diese Chargennummer eingeben und diese Chargennummer wird auch überprüft.
Also es wird zumindest mal gecheckt, dass da eine valide Eingabe auch erfolgt. Ist natürlich für die auch eine relevante Information, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man das nicht überprüfen könnte.
Ja
Na ja, da ist wieder aber das Problem, es gibt halt auch Leute, die kriegen gar keine Chargennummer eingeklebt beim Impfen oder da fällt der, ist der Aufkleber abgefallen äh oder so, das kommt halt auch vor,
Habe ich halt auch gesehen so. Und willst du dann den Leuten nur, weil denen irgendwie der Aufkleber jetzt abgefallen ist, äh dann äh sagen, nee, du bist jetzt nicht geimpft worden. Ich mein, äh ja.
Nö, aber ich meine, das ist eine Information, die man vielleicht später nochmal generieren kann. Also, solche Debatten werden da sicherlich geführt worden sein, aber worauf ich hinaus will, ist, man sollte sich klar machen, worum es sich bei diesem digitalen Impfpass handelt. So, es ist eine minimalen Nachweis.
Ja? Und die Daten sollen wohl am Ende ausschließlich auf den Endgeräten beim Benutzer,
vorliegen. Also die Daten, die da beim Ausstellen anfallen, äh äh sollen angeblich alle gelöscht äh werden, sobald man sie nicht mehr benötigt, für weil sie nicht Abrechnungszwecke oder so.
Das ist so. Das ist alles in diesem Zertifikat mit äh drin. Das ist technisch insofern äh ganz okay gemacht
auch noch so ein bisschen Problem ist und man kann diese Impfzertifikate auch nicht äh sperren lassen später, also wenn die einmal ausgefüllt sind, dann dann leben die quasi bis zum Ablaufdatum, die gelten aber dann auch irgendwie nur für zwölf Monate oder irgendwie so was oder achtzehn Monate. Ich weiß
mal ganz genau.
Ja, ich ich glaube, die haben für dreizehn Monate, glaube ich, wenn die wenn die da äh so Beschränkungen sind, glaube ich, auf dreizehn Monate ausgestellt, die Zertifikate. Keine Ahnung, was dann passiert.
Ja, das äh ist halt jetzt dieser digitale Impfpass. Die Frage ist natürlich jetzt so ein bisschen dabei ähm.
Was.
Passiert jetzt damit eigentlich, ne? Also viele können sich jetzt so ein, son, son, so ein, so ein Ding generieren lassen und offensichtlich,
ist das alles so angelegt, dass es möglichst einfach ist, dass äh Leute sowas haben. Frage ist, wo wird der dann zum Einsatz kommen.
Wofür wird er wirklich benutzt werden? Und schon mit so verschiedenen Gruppen gesprochen, die so theoretisch das machen könnten, aber da gibt's dann so die.
Verschiedensten Zweifel und Zurückhaltung, wie äh so was überhaupt erst zu erfordern.
Ja äh im Moment ist es ja so, äh dass du's äh brauchst, um zum Beispiel jemanden im Krankenhaus zu besuchen,
ja? Oder äh glaube ich auch im Altenheim oder alternativ ebenen Tagesaktuellen Test, also kannst alles.
Wofür du das Ding brauchst, kannst du auch immer mit einem tagesaktuellen Test oder vierundzwanzig Stunden alten Schnelltest, den du ja auch kostenlos an jeder Ecke kriegst.
Sozusagen ersetzen.
Dann für glaube ich Bewirtung in Innenräumen so.
Ist es auch erforderlich, draußen nicht, aber drinnen äh so, wenn du drin sitzen willst.
Ja und möglicherweise irgendwie größere Veranstaltungen kann ich mir auch vorstellen, äh dass es dazu.
Kommen wird, dass dann man dort auch entweder Test oder halt äh doppelte Impfung verlangt.
Natürlich fürs fürs Reisen äh so.
Ja äh kann kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass das dann für einen Check-In äh einfach auch ausreicht, dass sie dann nicht nochmal den Impfpass sehen wollen oder so. Wobei ich den schon wahrscheinlich mitnehmen würde, wenn ich auf Reisen ginge, weil.
Das ist halt ein Dokument mit einem UN-Siegel drauf. Äh.
So es gibt, das kennt jeder irgendwie.
Also ich meine diese dieser digitale Infos ist ja eh nur in der EU äh relevant, aber.
Und ich ich und ich würde halt auch nicht äh mich darauf verlassen, dass er überall in der EU auch bekannt ist.
Ja. Na klar. Ja.
Außerdem gibt's äh, wie schon erwähnt, so ein Update zur Corona-Warnapp, die jetzt übrigens seit einem Jahr draußen ist. Es gibt auf der äh Webseite.
Auch ein Rückblick auf äh das letzte Jahr äh wo auch so ein bisschen die Wirksamkeit analysiert wird.
Also sie versuchen mal so ein bisschen nachzu äh rechnen, was es denn jetzt eigentlich so wirklich gebracht hat. Kann ich jetzt gerade nicht so richtig ähm zusammenfassen, weil ich's äh die Zeit nicht mehr gehabt habe, mir das komplett durchzulesen. Vielleicht ähm habe ich mir das später nochmal nach.
Grundsätzlich muss man aber sagen, ähm es hat ein bisschen gedauert,
Mal glaube ich zu den Wert davon äh erkannt hat.
So eine App überhaupt zu haben, über die sich verschiedene Dinge so steuern und messen lassen
Aber ähm in letzter Zeit ist dann doch so die Intensität der Weiterentwicklung schon so ein bisschen nachhaltiger gewesen. Und das finde ich eigentlich super. Und ich denke, da ist äh auch immer noch eine ganze Menge Musik drin
Smartphones sind schon auch ganz gute Geräte, um irgendwie behilflich zu sein bei der Organisation solcher komplexer Vorgänge wie äh Reaktionen einer Gesellschaft, offene Pandemie.
Also.
Ein interessantes äh Ding oder eine interessante Zahl ist vielleicht, wenn ich das richtig sehe, haben sie in diesem Bericht auch ähm.
So
Ja ähm wie viele positive Testergebnisse haben die Labore übermittelt äh und zwar im Zeitraum erst irgendwann im Juli letzten Jahres äh begonnen. Insofern fehlen da,
so ein bisschen die die Daten von der, von der ersten Welle, aber da gab's ja auch noch nicht. Und ähm.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe, wurden irgendwie begab's anderthalb Millionen positive Tests.
So, die von den Laboren bereitgestellt wurden, also die hätten übermittelt werden können und davon wurde so nicht ganz ein Drittel,
so vierhundertdreiundsiebzigtausend wurden dann geteilt über die die App, also sagen sie gut.
Dreißig Prozent. Äh was äh ja ich eigentlich,
eine ganz beeindruckende Zahl finde. Ich meine fast eine halbe Million Testergebnisse, die äh geteilt äh wurden. Ähm,
das äh kann, je nachdem wie viel Kontakte äh das waren, weiß man halt nicht, aber äh.
So ähm ja doch Statistik, Tagesschlüssel geteilt.
Ja, auf jeden Fall so.
Haben sie da auf die Datenspende irgendwie nochmal zurückgegriffen und aus der Datenspende ergab sich das irgendwie dreihundertvierzehntausend rote Warnungen und fünfhundertvierundsiebzigtausend Grüne Warnungen.
Übermittelt wurden, was auch immer,
was jetzt bedeutet. Äh also sie schreiben das äh wahrscheinlich sagen es zwei bis dreimal äh so viele waren tatsächlich. Also.
Sagen, äh ja, irgendwie eine gute Million ähm.
Ein bis anderthalb Millionen Leute wurden halt gewarnt, was auch immer, das äh Ganze jetzt.
Dann am Ende verhindert haben mag an an Infektionen oder wie viele Leute dann.
Tatsächlich vielleicht frühzeitig sich haben, testen lassen, wahrscheinlich nie rausfinden, äh genau, aber.
Ja, äh aber zumindest dafür haben sie auch ein paar Zahlen in der, in der äh Untersuchung, dass sozusagen sechs Prozent wohl der der gewarnten äh der Rot gewarnten waren, dann tatsächlich positiv.
Ja, also da kommen auf jeden Fall.
Größere Mengen von Menschen zusammen. So und haben das ja schon mal gerechnet, also äh eine eine Infektion.
Kostet äh den Steuerzahler auf jeden Fall irgendeinen fünfstelligen Betrag im Schnitt, so und äh wenn man das halt dann mal.
Mal zehntausend irgendwas äh äh nimmt, kommt da halt auch schnell eine ganze Menge Kohle bei raus, die äh schnell auch mal das Budget übersteigt. Ähm was man jetzt für die Entwicklung dieser App ausgegeben hat.
Ja, ähm ich meine, wenn man sagt, dass.
Wahrscheinlich so ein paar tausend.
Infektionen eingespart wurden und war natürlich.
Dann ist immer ist immer schwer dann die die Folge sagen wir für Folgeinfektionen das jetzt waren, das hängt eigentlich immer davon ab.
Wie die wie der Inzidenzverlauf äh gerade ist. Aber ich denke, es gab auf jeden Fall einen Beitrag äh durch durch die.
App ähm so. Ähm ja.
Und äh sehr wahrscheinlich äh hat sie auch Leben gerettet, ja. Jetzt vielleicht nicht Tausende, aber äh sagen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich schon, vielleicht eine Handvoll, fünf oder zehn halte ich für realistisch, wenn ich mir das angucke, ja?
Die Zahlen, vielleicht auch mehr, vielleicht bis zu hundert äh so äh weiß man nicht, aber.
So für die fünf bis zehn Menschenleben hat die sehr wahrscheinlich schon gerettet.
Und vor allem hätte es noch sehr viel äh mehr helfen können, wenn einfach mehr Leute es installiert hätten. So und dafür gab's genug äh Gründe. Mal gucken. Aber es war jetzt auch unsere erste Pandemie mit Smartphone Präsenz. Äh von daher nächstes Mal wird's bestimmt unterhalten.
Mhm. Aber in meinen achtundzwanzig Komma eins Millionen war das jetzt in in an installierten äh an an Downloads oder an laufenden App.
Sprechen von Downloads und so eine richtige aktive Nutzungszahl haben sich irgendwie nie getraut rauszuspucken, was ich persönlich für, na ja
bisschen feige halte, weil das wäre problemlos zu generieren gewesen, diese Information liegt laufend vor, ne, man weiß einfach, wie viele Apps äh regelmäßig Kontakt haben mit dem Server, um sich die Schlüssel zu holen
man mühelos zählen können, auch ohne irgendwelche Datenschutzproblematiken äh ist nicht gemacht worden
finde ich nicht gut, weil so ehrlich muss man dann schon sein. Das sind einfach auch Zahlen, mit denen man arbeiten muss. Gut, vielleicht generieren sie diese Zahlen irgendwie intern
Aber das ist irgendwie Quatsch so. Also es ist äh das sollte man einfach transparent machen, das äh äh das kann so ein Gamification Faktor machen. Und nächstes Mal bitte dann halt auch gleich noch die Lotto
Ziehung da auch noch mit einbauen, weil das haben wir ja in den USA gesehen, das kann durchaus Wirkungen zeigen. Gut.
Zum Schluss würde ich gern nochmal auf ähm Christian Drosten zurückkommen.
Der ähm in den letzten.
Vor zwei Wochen, irgendwie gab's so ein Interview bei Republik CH mit ihm und der hat dann sich auch nochmal sehr ausführlich im Corona-Virus-Update-Podcast äh zu dieser Frage geäußert. Ähm.
Was die Herkunft dieses Virus betrifft.
Sehr hörenswert die Ausgabe vom Coronavirus Podcast. Neunzigste oder so. Ähm wo er nochmal,
sehr ausführlich auf all diese ganzen Argumente eingeht, so insbesondere um diese Verschwörungstheorien rund um dieses Labor in Wuhan und so weiter, ne? Also das war ja so ein bisschen so das, was dann medial noch mal hochgekocht wurde,
ähm.
Mehr und man hätte auch ganz gerne das äh das Virus irgendwie designed äh wurde, weil äh das,
heuchelt oder ja das das täuscht dann Kontrolle vor, wenn da irgendwelche Bösewichte dahinter stecken, als wenn das jetzt einfach durch Zufall durch die Natur passiert ist, aber ja, erzähl weiter.
Ja, also ich kann jetzt äh diesen Podcast, ehrlich gesagt, ausm Kopf nicht so richtig zusammenfassen. Ich habe mir in dem Moment auch keine Notizen äh gemacht, aber was ich so mitgenommen habe im Kern, ist äh erstmal.
Wie immer,
wenn man sich das genau anschaut, so die Situation ist ist kompliziert und komplexer als sie eben so diskutiert wird und es hat einfach ja eben was mit dieser Verkürzung zu tun,
Unterm Strich kann man sagen, auch wenn er äh sich niemals zu einer absoluten Aussage hinreißen lässt, dass für ihn äh nach wie vor die
sinnvollste Theorie die ist, dass zwei eigentlich dieselbe Quelle hat, wie saß eins,
auch. Und ähm verweist dabei auf Pilztierfarben in China,
erheblichen Anteil des Pelzmarktes weltweit auch äh haben. Er meinte, er wäre äh nach der ersten Pandemie davon also nach der ersten Epidemie mit ähm.
Saß eins davon ausgegangen, dass dass diese ähm.
Äh Farben entsprechend äh reguliert worden wären, was wohl so nicht stattgefunden hat. Das heißt, die haben da einfach so weiter gemacht wie vorher auch. Obwohl halt sehr zweifelfrei nachgewiesen werden konnte. Das saß eins eben dort übergesprungen ist.
Diese Tiere, die haben halt einen extrem bieten einen idealen Breadingground an. Wir hatten das ja hier auch mit diesen Märzfarmen in äh Dänemark und in Holland. Ja, die dann auch gekeult wurden und die dann auch verboten waren
wurden im Nachgang in China ist.
Ausgegraben.
Äh und wieder ausgegraben, genau äh nochmal einiges passiert. Ähm man,
halt und das ist wohl.
Vermieden worden, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, äh in China äh relativ schnell, indem man da mal konsequent hinterhergeforscht hätte
Ähm hätte man das schon nachweisen können, dem man da irgendwie so die Tiere auf äh entsprechende Antikörper untersucht hätte,
nicht erfolgt und es lässt sich halt in dem Sinne jetzt auch nicht äh wiederholen. Ähm das natürlich alles so ein bisschen
blöd, also ich glaube so richtig glücklich, wie es da gelaufen ist, ist niemand. Andererseits gibt's auch relativ wenig Erkenntnisse
die jetzt irgendwie wirklich einen Glauben lassen wollen würden, dass dass jetzt hier irgendein Design oder auch nur ein Unfall stattgefunden hat, ne? Am Ende ist auch dieser ganze Ausbruchsort Wuhan,
ähm dieser ominöse Markt, der in der Nähe des äh Labors, das ist natürlich alles sehr plakativ
die ähm größte Wahrscheinlichkeit, die er da äh sieht, ist, dass halt einfach irgendjemand sich auf so einer Pelztierfarm dieses Virus eingefangen hat, weil da ist dann für so eine Nähe, er meinte halt so, naja, die die Tiere werden nachher wie bei lebendigem Leib
äh schreiend entpelzt, ja.
Da ist viel Ariosol äh unterwegs, wenn äh wenn die Tiere so unter Stress sind, ne, abgesehen davon, dass sie sich dann halt ohnehin äh sich dann die Pfleger und Züchter oder wie man diese Leute dann auch nennen soll
sich dann halt einfach ohnehin viel in der Nähe dieser Tiere aufhalten,
und dann ist halt so ein Übersprungsszenario durchaus äh realistisch, ne und äh natürlich kann es sein, dass irgendso jemand.
Auf diesem Markt war, uns dort zu so Superspreader äh Event kam, ne. Das äh lässt sich ja heute alles überhaupt nicht mehr so richtig klären.
Also das vielleicht mal so als Anregung
das zu hören. Ich hätte jetzt leider nicht die Zeit, mir das noch ein zweites Mal anzuhören und so richtig im Detail diese ganze Herleitung äh zu machen. Äh das äh Interview auf Republik CH ist schon mal sehr äh gute Zusammenfassung.
Das hatte ich gelesen äh so und fand das jetzt auch durchaus plausibel und auch eine Erklärung,
mit der man mit der man leben kann äh finde ich wo man eher sich jetzt nicht irgendwie die nächsten zwanzig Jahre darüber aufregen,
müsste, schöner wäre es natürlich, wenn man das wüsste.
So äh aber äh damit auch dann sozusagen zu arbeiten, weil von eins weiß man's ja offen.
Und äh jetzt bei saß zwei auch davon auszugehen und zu vermeiden, dass vielleicht von da dann auch nochmal in SARS drei kommt. Ich hoffe, dass die Chinesen dann langsam,
aufgewacht sind, aber ich höre halt immer wieder von China, dass so ein Problem ist, dass die zwar auf der einen Seite super harsch äh sind, so, auch in ihren Strafen und wie sie dann,
Gesetzesbrecher vorgehen, aber das machen sie dann so einmal im Jahr oder vielleicht einmal alle fünf Jahre,
so, dann hauen sie da irgendwie drauf und stecken Leute in in Knast und oder errichten die hin oder was auch immer, wenn sie sich zu Schulden kommen lassen, aber,
so äh dann äh irgendwie am nächsten Tag oder oder einen Monat später oder so, ist ja,
ist alles wieder so, wie es wie es vorher war, weil das eben nicht dann wohl nicht regelmäßig gemacht wird, wenn's nicht irgendwie um politische Dinge äh geht oder Sachen gegen das Regime, sondern nur normale Kriminalität,
oder so. Äh da will man dann jetzt auch nicht allzu sehr die gesellschaftliche Harmonie stören, indem man dann irgendwie jetzt äh ja.
Also indem das zu offensichtlich äh wird und so und äh ja, wie auch immer, also ja.
Hoffen wir, dass sich in diesem Jahr.
Kurve kriegen.
Kurve kriegen, ja? Und uns nicht nochmal äh sowas bescheren.
So, jetzt sind wir so ein bisschen am Schluss äh angekommen. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, ob's schon äh stadthaft ist. Hm,
nochmal so.
Unseren Blick auf die ganze Pandemie und was bisher so geschah, äh zu liefern. So ganz habe ich noch nicht so den Eindruck, dass dass der Zeitpunkt schon gekommen ist, das äh komplett abzurunden.
Nee, ich glaube, das braucht dann auch eine komplett eigene Sendung, äh die dann halt nichts anderes enthält oder vielleicht auch vier Sendungen oder so für.
Pro Welle.
Pro Welle eine Provelle, genau. Äh und ne, ne. Und es ist schon natürlich eine unglaubliche Menge an.
Informationen, die wir hier durch genudelt äh haben, sage ich mal und.
Ausgehen, ja, von der Überlegung, oh Gott, was passiert hier eigentlich.
Äh so und wo wo geht das Ganze hin? Wie wie schlimm wird es denn? Und dann äh ja ich angefangen zu rechnen und wir haben dann angefangen darüber zu reden und das Ganze.
Ist dann.
Eskaliert. So kann man das, glaube ich, sagen äh und äh bis dahin, dass wir jetzt was einundfünfzig Mal darüber dreiundfünfzig Mal darüber geredet.
Mal heute.
Fünfzig, das ist jetzt zweiundfünfzig Mal.
Geredet haben so im Schnitt wahrscheinlich zwei Stunden oder so, das heißt, wir haben jetzt auf jeden Fall also die hundert Stunden.
Haben wir haben wir definitiv voll, ja. Und ansonsten,
Auf jeden Fall man, was ich jetzt schon sagen kann, für mich eine.
Wirklich einmalige, besondere Lebenserfahrung, von der ich irgendwann wahrscheinlich auch sagen werde, dass ich sie nicht missen möchte, wie viele andere Lebenserfahrungen auch.
Wenn ich sagen darauf hätte vielleicht verzichten können äh so äh sagen im Nachhinein oft ist es mir so gegangen, was weiß ich.
Mit der Bundeswehrzeit oder so, wo ich auch gerne drauf äh hätte verzichten können, aber das äh war halt nicht so möglich. Und da habe ich gesagt, naja gut, wenn ich dann schon hin muss, dann richtig.
Und äh so war's dann wahrscheinlich jetzt hier bei irgendwie Pandemie dann auch zumindest, was Informationen angeht dann, ja, wenn.
Wenn Corona dann, wie schon die volle Ladung an Informationen und das war nicht immer leicht, fand ich so, also das merkt man, glaube ich, auch.
Sich so manche Podcasts anhört, dass das schon ein bisschen ein äh rauf und runter auch bei Stimmungen und Launen.
War, dass wir da auch nicht nicht irgendwie immer immun liegen waren, gegen.
Aufregung, uns aufzuregen und äh und für mich war aber auch, sagen diese Zeit jetzt sehr, sehr viel Zeit, einfach zu Hause zu verbringen.
Und äh ja äh das hat dann auch dazu geführt hm dass ich mir.
Sich unglaublich viel gelernt habe. Also nicht nur jetzt über Corona, sondern eben auch über ganz viele andere Dinge und.
Und da habe ich das Gefühl, dass das, was ich so gelernt habe auch in der Coronazeit, doch noch mal so eine prägende Erfahrung äh war, die.
Glaube ich die Gestaltung meiner Zukunft äh doch.
Nachhaltig auch beeinflusst haben dürfte, so auch wenn ich noch nicht weiß, wo es jetzt hingeht, aber.
Für mich sind jetzt schon ganz viele Dinge, die ich sag mal, ich für Corona noch.
Irgendwie richtig oder wichtig oder erstrebenswert äh äh gehalten habe, sind für mich jetzt,
ja, weniger wichtig, weniger richtig oder oder falsch und vielleicht nicht mehr so erstrebenswert, insofern ja.
Also schon 'ne prägende Erfahrung und insofern ja historisch, historisch.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall, jetzt schon, jetzt schon historischer Podcast.
Jetzt schon. Ich rede von der Pandemie, aber äh.
Na ja und und im eigenen äh Erleben so, ne. Also es ist für einen selber natürlich dann schon irgendwie historisch. Also, ja klar, also ich bin auf jeden Fall auch sehr froh, ähm.
Relativ früh ähm für mich so die Entscheidung gefällt zu haben, okay, wenn schon Pandemie dann richtig,
also wenn ich mir das jetzt mal andersrum vorstelle, ich hätte jetzt irgendwie anfangs so eine Verdrängungs.
Verdrängungsdruck gespürt, so nach dem Motto, oh, da kommt was Gefährliches. Das ignoriere ich jetzt mal. Ja, das wird schon wieder weggehen.
Sicherlich viele Leute auch so gehabt haben und
aus dem dann vielleicht auch nicht wieder rausgekommen sind. Was natürlich dann immer genau dann schwierig ist, dass wenn du dann doch mal wieder auftauchst so aus deinem aus deinem Tauchgang, äh der Ignoranz.
Situation konfrontiert siehst, in der du dann eben einfach diese Regeln gar nicht mehr nachvollziehen kannst. Ich hatte jetzt irgendwie letztes Wochenende.
Auf dem Campingplatz auch mal eine Person getroffen, die ich halt nicht kannte, da so auf dem Campingplatz man kommt so als ein Gequatsche und na ja, man unterhält sich ja heutzutage irgendwie nach fünf Minuten sowieso immer wieder über äh die Pandemie auf die ein oder andere Art und Weise,
Naja und ich habe so ein bisschen so meinen,
Mein Fazit in in zehn Minuten mal so hingelegt, so was ich so generell davon halte, ne? Wo ja schnell, sagen wir mal, meine Grundhaltung äh rauskommt. Und weißt du, ja die Leute, die da halt irgendwie äh.
Skeptisch sind, kann ich halt nicht.
Nicht so ohne Weiteres nachvollziehen, ne? Meinst du, naja so äh kannst du ja jetzt mal gleich mal testen irgendwie, weil sie wäre da irgendwie skeptisch, ne? Haben wir da so ein bisschen hin und her diskutiert und,
meinte dann nach dem Gespräch so, ja, okay, jetzt hätte sie wahrscheinlich das erste Mal so ein paar Sachen überhaupt erst verstanden,
Ja, so diese, was wir uns ja auch hier so selber eigentlich äh in mühevoller Kleinstarbeit zusammen sortiert haben, so dieser Grundeinstellung zu Lockdowns. Dieses, diese Feststellung.
Was wirkt, was wirkt nicht und warum wirkt irgendwas nicht? Äh und dass man sich eigentlich sehr viel mehr
leitete äh ersparen können, wenn man halt einfach kräftiger reagiert. Und das ist schon dann auch etwas, was man dann gut darlegen kann und das macht mich persönlich natürlich für mich selber sehr,
glücklich jetzt in so einer äh Situation zu sein, einfach auch eine Position beziehen zu können und die im Zweifelsfall auch vertreten zu können.
Nicht nur irgendwie so eine Meinung ist, sondern die die auf etwas aus auf realer Analyse und konkret greifbaren Daten und Fakten
basiert und die man irgendwie äh im Prinzip auch, wenn man jetzt alle äh Details gerade mal nicht so parat hat, sich mehr oder weniger auch aus sich selbst heraus herleiten kann.
Also zum Beispiel Schlüsselmoment in diesem Gespräch war, dass sie dann gleich am Anfang meinte so, na ja, aber gucke mal, am Anfang,
da gingen doch die Zahlen schon zurück bevor die ersten Maßnahmen beschlossen.
So und dann wusste ich sofort, woher der Wind weht. Die war jetzt irgendwie keine Verschwörungstheoretikerin oder sonst.
Das kam ja halt merkwürdig vor. Und das ist so wahrscheinlich etwas, was zehn, zwanzig Leute in ihrem Leben in irgendeiner Form immer wieder aus der Hosentasche gezogen haben und so nach dem Motto daran kann man ja sehen, dass.
So und dann naja, dann habe ich halt gesagt, ja klar, kann ich dir erklären. Und dann bin dann halt äh sofort mit dieser These gekommen, na ja.
Erst kommen halt die Nachrichten und dann kommen irgendwie äh die Maßnahmen und äh es sind immer die Nachrichten, das ist immer die Nachrichtenlage, äh die äh die ersten Wirkungen ausführt, aber sie hätten halt auch alleine nicht gereicht und und das,
war dann schon sofort so ein,
so ein Kick in diesem Gespräch, wo sie dann später meinte, so, ah, okay, alles klar, jetzt äh verstehe ich mal, was eigentlich Sache ist. Und da bin ich doch sehr froh, mich jetzt auch,
selbst in so eine Situation versetzt haben und auch froh, vielleicht viele auch andere dadurch in so eine Situation versetzt zu haben, einfach äh dieser.
Stresssituation für die gesamte Gesellschaft so halbwegs mündig gegenüber zu stehen.
Das ist eine ganz gute Beschreibung tatsächlich und mich hatte auch mehrere so dieser Erlebnisse.
Sag ich mal nicht, dass ich immer alle Leute überzeugen konnte so, aber ja ich hab mich,
auch durchaus sehr sicher meistens in der Argumentation äh gefühlt und äh wenn äh dann,
dort auch plötzlich sich Lücken aufgetan haben oder ich für irgendwas keine Erklärung hatte, dann fand ich das auch immer sehr anregend. Äh dann äh mich auf die Suche zu machen und das dann rauszufinden und so. Und,
sicherlich nicht immer mit allem so äh hundert Prozent richtig gelegen äh denke ich.
Was wir so erwartet haben. Wir sind auch hier und da überrascht worden. Aber es wäre wirklich mal interessant, das mal systematisch sich anzuhören.
Das ist äh wahrscheinlich viel zu aufwendig, um äh das wirklich mal genau äh nachzurechnen oder objektiv mal zu sehen, äh wie,
Ja, ähm wie gut wir auch letztlich darin äh waren, bestimmte.
Entwicklungen dann irgendwann eben auch zu erwarten oder nicht zu erwarten.
So und ich fand das eben auch sehr, sehr interessant äh also.
Ähm wie dann doch äh immer wieder äh ist Überraschungen,
äh so, äh weil natürlich es ist schon alles eine extrem komplexe Geschichte ist. Und da Faktoren reinwirken,
die wir alle nicht wirklich kennen oder unter Kontrolle haben plus, dass.
Einfach die Daten auch sehr sehr miserabel sind.
Äh ich meine, ein großer Teil dessen, was wir gemacht haben, war ja auch immer die Daten zu interpretieren, weil
ähm so okay, die Zahlen gehen jetzt hoch, liegt's jetzt an irgendwie mehr Tests oder weniger Tests oder
liegt es jetzt an den Infektionen und was ist mit der Dunkelziffer so, wie entwickelt sich die und.
Ja äh und wie wie groß sind denn jetzt die einzelnen Einfluss äh Faktoren und das ist halt auch so eine unendliche Geschichte, weil.
Nur weil man,
in einer Untersuchung jetzt die Wirksamkeit äh einer bestimmten Maßnahme äh so und so statistisch entwickelt hat, heißt es nicht, dass wenn man dieselbe Maßnahme das nächste Mal oder in irgendeinem anderen Land,
oder so äh äh anwendet, dass man dann die gleichen Ergebnisse erwarten äh kann und da halt sagen dieses, dieses ganze
Spiel, sagen sich, sich da in auf der einen Seite doch,
statistischen Wahrscheinlichkeiten äh zu äh bewegen, aber eben auch dann Unsicherheiten.
Und eben ja äh in in Wahrscheinlichkeiten zu denken, das fällt halt vielen Leuten, glaube ich, auch schwer.
Eigentlich äh ein wichtiger Teil des Lebens in allen Lebensbereichen und jetzt nicht nur bei Corona, sondern.
Von irgendwie ganz klein von der nächsten Sekunde bis irgendwie über,
Entscheidungen, die deren Folgen über Jahre hinweg äh dann sich sich auswirken in,
all diesen Fällen geht es darum irgendwie 'ne,
bestimmte Zukunft oder Varianten von Zukunft zu entwerfen und dann äh zu sehen, wie man denn die Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit äh von den Varianten von Zukunft, die man gerne hätte, äh erhöhen,
kann. So und.
Da deswegen ist vielleicht sich mit Corona zu beschäftigen, auch so sinnstiftend, weil es sagen so eine, so eine grundsätzliche äh Sache ist, die wir eigentlich ständig,
mehr oder weniger in einem bestimmten Umfang.
Und ja, das das äh ich meine, das hast du ja auch gemerkt, als dann angefangen hast, so mit den Impfungen und so, dir die anzuschauen, dass das das da schon auch eine gewisse,
ähm man eine gewisse Befriedigung äh rauszieht. Also es ist.
Bestimmtes Informationsbedürfnis steht oder ein ein Bedürfnis stillt die Welt zu verstehen und vielleicht das Bedürfnis nach Kompetenz zu befriedigen.
An der Stelle. Ja.
Nicht so auf alles auf Hören sagen basieren zu lassen. So, ich meine, meine,
Auswertungen sind jetzt auch nicht mega ambitioniert, da gibt's noch eine ganze Menge, was man noch äh machen könnte und gerade so Fälle wie
Jetzt fehlen hunderttausend, so, da hätte ich dann auch ganz gerne noch mal ein bisschen genauer reingeschaut und dann das äh aufgespalten nach Ländern und so weiter. Ähm gut, das
jetzt dann nicht mein primäres Ziel gewesen. Mir geht's da äh primär darum, überhaupt erstmal den
den Fortschritt zu verstehen. Das funktioniert soweit ja auch ganz gut, aber du hast schon Recht. Es ist einfach so eine
etwas mehr Intensität und auch Bereitschaft mit Zahlenmaterial aufzunehmen ist auf jeden Fall ein ganz dankbare Maßnahme.
Und dann in andere Länder zu gucken und zu sehen, ja äh nimmt das bei uns vielleicht jetzt denselben Weg oder dieselbe Entwicklung und
es hat für mich auch ganz, ganz viel Anlass gegeben über unterschiedliche Kulturen und Gesellschaften äh nachzudenken. Also gerade auch das Beispiel Tschechien, wo ich ja nun in Prag geboren äh bin
Tschechien halt auch äh sagen sehr nahe äh steht.
Und zu sehen wie das da gelaufen ist, das war für mich auch nochmal so 'ne ganz.
Erfahrung somit die erste Welle perfekt gemeistert und dann es geschafft so in der zweiten und dritten und vierten Welle so einfach weiß ich nicht,
ob das jetzt so schwelgmäßig war, nach dem Motto nee,
es reicht uns jetzt mit mit diesem mit dieser Pandemie so, wir lassen uns davon jetzt nicht irgendwie.
Das Feiern verderben, ja? Und dementsprechend scheint das dann auch gelaufen zu sein. Ja.
Gut, ich würde sagen, damit können wir äh die Sendung jetzt erstmal hier beenden, ne.
Ja, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören auf jeden Fall. Also, wir machen jetzt eine kleine Pause, aber äh wir kommen wieder, ne, also allein schon um die ganzen Wellen nochmal zu besprechen.
Vielleicht kommt ja noch eine, die wir dazu nehmen müssen und wenn äh irgendein was Nennenswertes passiert, wir müssen Zeit haben, dann machen wir vielleicht nochmal so eine kleine Sendung zwischendurch, aber Corona Weekly ist jetzt erstmal äh bis auf Weiteres nicht ganz so weekly.
Ähm,
Ja, vielen Dank äh an der Stelle vielleicht auch mal an alle, äh die sich so beteiligt haben, einerseits so in den Kommentaren, da kann man immer wirklich sehr viel, da konnten wir leider nicht immer darauf eingehen, das ähm also
man vielleicht tun können, aber es äh war viel, aber auf jeden Fall immer äh sehr interessante Debatten und und ähm viele der Quellen, die wir hier genannt haben, kamen auch letzten Endes daher
sehr erfolgreich fand ich auch das ganze Engagement mit Clubhaus,
in beide Richtungen, einerseits, glaube ich, konnte man so ein paar Informationen dann auch nochmal vertiefen, das hat ja dann auch nochmal ein paar Zuhörer gehabt, die vielleicht gar nicht so sehr den Podcast kannten, auch wenn, glaube ich, die Mehrheit,
schon war, ja, für die Leute, die das nicht so verfolgt haben. Also, wir hatten jetzt eigentlich jede Woche so immer so zwei, dreihundert Leute, die daran äh teilgenommen haben und dann.
Gingen die Sessions so bis zu vier Stunden äh und in diesen vier Stunden haben wir dann mal so irgendwas zwischen,
so zehn, zwanzig Leute, die irgendwie mit auf die Bühne gekommen sind und äh alle möglichen
hinterfragt oder angesprochen haben, oft dann eben auch Beteiligte, äh viele, die so ausm
Aus der Intensivmedizin kamen, die er so äh von ihren Erlebnissen und Eindrücken und und Arbeitsbedingungen berichtet haben. Auch Ärzte, Virologen, äh war alles dabei, ne, die.
Lehrer, Eltern äh.
Genau. Mit Kita, mit Kindern, in Schule und so weiter, also so alle Betroffene in irgendeiner Form ab. Das heißt alle, aber
viele, viele unterschiedliche äh Blickwinkel, die dabei kamen und das interaktive Format von Clubhaus fand ich an der Stelle auch sehr hilfreich. Es ging auch eigentlich immer sehr zivilisiert zu.
Haben uns da auch äh wenig Schwurbel eingetreten.
Ne und.
Und äh die paar, äh die dann reinkamen und es versucht haben, muss ich sagen, äh haben auch guten Content geliefert, definitiv.
Auf ihre Art, ja. Mhm.
Nee, insgesamt immer also man so so vielfältige äh auch nette Erlebnisse zum Teil, was weiß ich, äh jemand, der.
Auch dringenden Impftermin brauchte, dem dann zufällig geholfen werden konnte. Äh er durch einen anderen Hörer.
Der noch einen übrig hatte äh äh irgendwie sowas, da hat er glaube ich genau im richtigen. Äh Zufall äh ja.
Ja, nee und ganz viele Leute, die auch regelmäßig wieder dazugekommen sind und Fortschritte haben und aus dem Ausland sagen viele anekdotische Berichte äh und so, also ja,
eigentlich auch äh alles sehr nette Veranstaltungen, auch wenn natürlich so äh ja.
Zweimal pro Woche irgendwie mehrere Stunden äh aufzuwenden äh einem auch nicht immer leicht gefallen ist, so muss ich, muss ich sagen.
Ne? Doch äh da aber wir sind, glaube ich, die ganz diszipliniert dabei geblieb.
Ja, es ist tatsächlich viel Zeit äh reingeflossen. Also ich würde sagen,
KW hat jetzt so in den letzten Monaten locker.
Ich das mal so alles zusammenzähle. Also einerseits geht mehr oder weniger der ganze Tag,
Für mich jetzt zumindest drauf, äh die Sendung zu produzieren. Man muss
am Tag sich immer vorbereiten, man muss sich auch so ein bisschen in diesen Modus bringen, muss man mal seine ganzen Notizen zusammensuchen, habe ich auch alle Links äh habe ich mir den Artikel gut durchgelesen, mache ich mir vielleicht nochmal besser
Notizen, um das dann auch wirklich klar vorbringen zu können, dann äh
dauert's ja dann äh äh auch eine Weile, zwei Stunden Sendung, heißt ja dann, man sitzt manchmal aber auch drei Stunden da, weil man halt vorher irgendwie noch quatscht und äh manchmal auch danach. Und äh ja auch beim Schneideprozess äh habe ich relativ viel Zeit investiert, überhaupt ähm habe ich in der ganzen Coronazeit
sehr viel mehr Energie in den Schnitt.
Um einfach nochmal die Sendung äh ein bisschen zu entzerren, äh akustisch äh auf jeden Fall maximal äh erlebbar zu machen.
Ja und am Ende mit dieser ganzen Zwischenrecherche, weil man eigentlich so viel aktiver dann auch die Nachrichten einsammelt, also so dieses
man klickt den nicht nur so rum, sondern ist so A okay Studie, zack, linkssicher, nochmal durchlesen, hier nochmal gucken, äh hatten wir das schon mal? Äh also man man sammelt dann ein und und gefühlt ist so
jeden Tag eigentlich immer auch nochmal so eine Stunde oder so weggegangen, weil man einfach.
Konsumiert hat, genauer nachgelesen hat, was man sonst vielleicht nicht so intensiv aufgenommen hätte.
Erden bei mir noch äh teilweise sehr, sehr lange und ausführliche Twitter-Shreads, die noch dazu äh gekommen sind, so wo mancher Twitter Sweat äh allein mich einen halben Tag gekostet hat, äh sagen denen.
Ja mit Text und Bildern zu versehen, also das sicherlich auch nicht wofür Twitter mal ursprünglich gedacht war.
Und eigentlich hätte ich eher gedacht, dass sich sowas eher in mein Blog gehört, aber irgendwie.
Kann man den Blog die Sachen halt nachträglich wieder erinnern und ich wollte einfach auch 'ne,
sagen, eine öffentliche Dokumentation dessen haben, so was sich zu welchem Zeitpunkt gesagt habe, aber Twitter ist halt miserabel durchsuchbar, finde ich. Sie suche in Twitter, ist das ein Horror.
Ist ein Horror, aber dafür hat man einfach diese diese wunderbare äh spontane äh Interaktion, ne, also
die dies äh also muss sagen, äh du hast mich dann auch so ein bisschen zu diesem Stretch-Schreiben gebracht, das habe ich vorher gar nicht so aktiv,
praktiziert. Ähm gerade äh einerseits zu manch anderen äh Themen, aber dann vor allem jetzt so für dieses tägliche Impfupdate
mir das so äh zurechtgelegt und das ähm ja, das ist auch in der Tat intensiv, aber eben auch immer wieder ein
guter äh Konzentrationstest, um auch einfach mal zu sehen, so okay, was,
was kriege ich jetzt hier eigentlich wirklich rausgelesen aus diesem Zahlenmaterial? Ist das heute alles irgendwie Business oder gibt's hier irgendwie irgendeine versteckte Kleinigkeit, die die die man mal erwähnen sollte, selbst wenn man sie selber nicht versteht und dann kommen dann halt auch immer äh
passende Tipps und, und, und, und Hinweise, äh was sind das nun vielleicht wieder sein könnte, welche Anomalie da jetzt wieder aufgetreten ist?
Aber insgesamt ist es halt ein kompletter äh Information Overflow, also.
So ich ich glaube, dass selbst wir, die da irgendwie mitten in diesem ganzen Schlauch.
Stehen äh Hochdruckinformationsabfüllmaschinen namens Internet äh dass wir auch vielleicht.
Impromille Bereich äh grade äh mal äh unterwegs sind, was so Nachrichten angeht, die es überhaupt gibt, aber man muss natürlich auch irgendwie priorisieren und.
Denke ich, die Sachen aufgreifen, die sich dann in der öffentlichen Debatte befinden. Aber ich denke, wir haben immer wieder auch selber Akzente gesetzt und selber auch immer wieder Themen.
Glaube ich, aufgebracht, die dann äh ja oft erst nach Wochen oder Monaten irgendwann plötzlich dann.
Gesprächsthema in den Mainstream Medien wurden.
Gut kommen wir zum Ende langsam.
Genau,
Ja, vielen Dank äh an der Stelle auch äh für alle äh an alle, die äh die Meterebene dann auch aktiv finanziell unterstützt haben.
Vielleicht finden sich ja auch noch ein paar, äh die da mit äh einsteigen wollen, Meterebene ist äh wie immer, Kosten, Werbe und äh Bullshit frei. Das ist mir immer total wichtig, dass dass das auch so
bleibt und äh ein gewisser Hinsicht war es auch ein sehr angenehmer Luxus, diesen.
So freigekauft zu äh werden und einfach sich komplett irgendwie so einem Thema auch widmen zu können,
Für die, die so ein bisschen den anderen Content vermissen, äh er wird kommen so
ist erstmal so ein bisschen Sommerpause, aber ich hoffe äh wenn sich denn so eine vierte Welle und weitere Lockdowns vermeiden äh lassen, dass ich dann auch so um ein normales Programm wieder aufnehme, sprich die ganzen Interview-Sachen. Äh auch bei UKW muss dann äh sicherlich ja nochmal
neue Bandbreite gefunden werden, ein paar Ideen habe ich da schon. Geht auf jeden Fall alles weiter. Vielen Dank äh an der Stelle auf jeden Fall für alle, die sich da bereit erklären.
Mitzuhelfen. So und das war's würde ich sagen für heute ähm wir sagen tschüss und bis bald.